eth great hello everybody it is January
29th the year 2024 the sponsor gamer
subs thank you to them thank you to
gamer Subs we love them how's everybody
doing happy Monday is Hope youall don't
have a case of the
Mondays no but seriously um how's
everybody doing lovely wonderful thank
you Monday baby happy to be here hell
yeah hell yeah hell yeah me too actually
we have a all great episode we got so
much fun stuff to discuss as you guys
can see in the title Austin MC Brom is
continuing to descend
into I feel bad for him now genuinely
like this
is I well I feel it's gotten so weird
that people are questioning if it's even
real I'm one of those and I feel this
we'll just we'll have to debate that
when we come to it but it is quite good
it's quite intriguing the whole thing
um ab and preach made a video attacking
me coming at me they were even being
anti-semitic which I'm just kidding they
weren't I'll put a stop to that right
now they were not being anti-semitic
there was a glint in their eyes where I
was like he wants to tell a Jew joke
right now I could tell there's something
about what was in his eyes I was like
there's just that dude is wanting to say
the k word right now no I'm kidding I'm
just kidding is that too much the k
word too much I mean you didn't say it
it's a big accusation to throw around I
said I'm kidding
okay the joke is that they didn't and I
you know it was just the
glimmer that's the joke no they were
they were actually somewhat nice I'd say
I feel like there might be a bridge
building
could there be a b a bridge
building it's entirely up to you sir it
is you think you're the master Bridge
Burner yeah you know that's kind of your
thing that's bro I'm the B I'm
an architect I'm a engineer I build
Bridges oh for example Jeff
Whit that's true t f that's okay that's
one too um Brad the Martin you burned it
again kind when did I burn it again it's
shaky well you know in in a in a war
field in a Battleground sometimes you
just need like the quick inflatable
Bridges MH mhm they're not permanent
fixtures so that might be what that is
but um let's see I'll watch
that okay here was a post on the
subreddit
about I don't know who remembers the
Forbidden Ethan
Bradberry Co video oh I remember um we I
wanted to work with Ethan we becoming
friends and I I respect
his whatever it is he is tenac slam on
them with
the that was iconic they showed up in
the Spider-Man and Elsa I mean it was
great Ethan Bradberry is genuinely very
funny like who would have guessed that
back in the day when you were making
reactions he's just an odd dude I mean
you know talk
nice the the raw the regular raw Saga I
was so invested in that man I really was
trying to find the r of the RO bring it
back I wonder what they're doing for
money watching are they doing I don't
think they're doing I think they like do
a lot of like crypto stuff to be honest
they're on the side I think so nice well
maybe not even on the side I think I've
mostly seen that from uh from Mo look I
all I know about those two dudes is that
they're Natural Born Hustlers that is
true without a doubt
you know anyway um there was a post on
the sub that reminded us all Ethan are
you w to release the Ethan Bradberry Co
video now that enough time has passed so
what
happened as we said let's just do a man
on the street type of thing uh go to New
York and just ask people what they think
about covid mhm cuz I was like you know
it was right at the beginning of the uh
I don't think had lockdown even beun
clearly it was like when people were
worried about that about to happen no
there was no lockdown as evidenced by
the video itself cuz he's in right right
good point Thank
you so uh we said hey go do a man on the
street and just talk to New Yorkers
about uh Co because I thought you know
Ethan's a character and New Yorkers are
characters so it should be something
interesting but what Ethan sent
us is something that none of us expected
although maybe we should have it was
so
inflammatory that I and you guys know I
don't like
to pass I like to show you guys
everything and even me I looked at that
and I said we shouldn't show that cuz
one not only does it risk us but I think
he actually might have done something
illegal and at the time people were so
sensitive he may actually have been
arrested I genuinely think that that
could have turned into a huge Scandal we
uh we just wanted some roving reporter
work from him and he uh delivered so so
I did not request him to do any of I
said just man on the street I didn't pay
him I I frankly have no association with
what I what I'm about to show you I and
I condemn it in the strongest possible
words in fact I don't think it even
happened around covid I think it
happened in
Minecraft uh just a few months ago you
know what I'm saying it
did so the timeline of this I will say I
think what I'll
say if if anyone from YouTube's watching
cuz I want them to know the real story
is this was filmed last month and we're
pretending like it was shot during Co
for a dramatic purpose but it was not MH
this is a reenactment right every this
is no there's no because there's nothing
to reenact right oh okay not even that
not real this is fiction this is just a
dramatization yeah well that still
implies it's of some sort of of this is
just fiction this is a fictional story
made to it actually it's it's not even
Co it's it's some other pandemic FL
season yeah one one of the other
pandemics covid 20 so
um there's been some Reser it's so
up you know some people are
reserved if we shouldn't even show it
now
but I feel that you know at the time I
said in a few years I'm going to show
this here let me let me and does anyone
have a link when I talked about it
because it was so the fact that so many
years have passed send it earlier yeah
and now we're here and behind Co is
behind us well behind us right the world
has moved on uh yeah Co still exists
though well I know that but like it's
out of style it's out of style it's you
know it's not the it girl anymore it's
boring or noce it it's cool it's all
good I don't know if it's all good
well it's all good it's all we got
vacines we got the hospitals are are
cool I even at the um like Kaiser place
that was on lockdown for so long they
got rid of all the covid they had
like a little Tent City in front to test
anybody coming into the hospital M it's
all
gone Co is done we beat
it we beat that we made it I'm
really excited to uh to watch this I I
haven't seen it yet so you have never
seen it this was before your time yeah
it was right before my time who has seen
it Dan well I did yeah Z you've seen it
right well he I was the one
corresponding with him so I saw the raw
the raw the raw
baby yeah I did this edit there was a
lot of footage oh you edit it yeah yeah
we had to dig deep we had to dig deep
for this one um so he just dumped a
whole bunch of footage on you guys yeah
yeah oh
this is actually after dark one I
started after dark 2 was my first
episode so yeah right before me so
there's half the office in here is I'm
about to see this for the first time I
inquired about it when I started it's
like you did when you become president
and you want to know about aliens I
would the second I got in I was like I
need to see that I would have shown
you I did I did see it oh you did see it
yeah yeah so was it as bad
as as I'm building it up to be yeah it's
pretty bad yeah it's Prett it's pretty
bad it's as bad as it could get yeah
it's as bad as a yeah I've seen it and
it's
bad okay so a lot of us have seen it who
hasn't seen it I've seen it Olivia oh
okay me Lena and Olivia I think okay oh
I'm so
excited no I'm not it's going to be
horrible well it's just a reenactment
right it's a sketch comedy yes ab's
funny he's a comedian he's a sketch
comedy
mhm
um call him ab ab or I mean I'll take it
thank you I mean uh e t it's two
letters what are you going to do huh
talk to me
nice do we have the clip of me talking
about it yeah I sent it oh you did talk
to me nice Ethan here I am talking about
it God what was this 5 years ago now
this video this the date of this is and
then when I saw this I was like dude I
can't like this first of what's the date
on this three years ago hover over it
and I'll tell you oh there it is August
21st 2020 okay three and a half years
three and a half years
is so let's see all is horrible and I
can't show it and I wish you didn't do
this that being said here is the
Bradberry report which I condone in the
most wait I did wait hold on what is
this this is what we were trying to tell
you you played audio for no where's the
first time the first
time oh when I was like I'll watch this
in years when CO's done I don't know
where that one is okay so we yeah we
played the audio of it I didn't want to
show
it so some people have seen bits of
it but here is the regular the
raw and uh remember especially if anyone
from YouTube's watching this is just a
sketch and it took place last
week and everybody in it are actors too
all the um extras are actors you you
guys know how YouTube pranksters are
every everybody's an actor it's all
pre-planned
so are you crazy there's no crimes mind
no
crimes all right Ethan here it is at
long
last we're with a regular RW Central
today in the route of New York City I
just want to know your thoughts for the
corona what Corona yeah what do you what
are your thoughts on the
Corona from the
stair by the way like like you have to
understand this was at the height of the
co hysteria like people were scared
people were
scared
huh I have
it I have it that's why you know what
I'm saying I'm just trying to enjoy my
last few
moments I guess we enjy together huh I
guess we are enjoying together
yeah
Central today all right man stay
safe stay
safe pleas dude he is such a drip I'm
sorry but Ethan's a wild man
he's wild he definitely delivered okay
this was one of the ones where I was
like oh yeah we we can't this was one of
the real bad
ones last week in Minecraft that'd be a
good someone wrote that that'd be a good
name for a segment mhm last week in
Minecraft where you show clips that if
it weren't in Minecraft it would be a
problem I can't get in here how
many he's trying to get in a taxi and
he's insisting he's insisting on sitting
in the front seat and the guy is saying
no no no getting back obviously cuz
social distancing he's got the windows
down that's what everyone was saying to
do but Ethan insists on sitting in the
front seat the back hold the back yeah
here okay you here
okay so the guy's accommodating he's
moving his backpack he's letting him set
nice guy
Franklin
okay but
[Music]
uh before I go like
um I'm with I'm with a regular raw
Central today huh yeah um what do you
think of the Corona virus
I don't know why why you won't go or no
no what do you think about the Corona
virus I don't know I have no idea how
they have to
do I have it so so so why you
go I told you go over
there but I want to sit in the front no
you go over the
back man man open the
door open the door yeah
yeah open the door I can't be no but
what do you think about the v no open
the door listen I have I have a few you
know moments okay open the
door
off why are we moving
new uh can you weigh a little cuz Okay
I'll be way
yeah dude is a
maniac by the way and like in this
sketch that never happened even in this
sketch his character doesn't actually
have Co he's pretending
he's perfectly healthy in the
[Music]
sketch I listen I told y all was
up people are like as a germophobe I
hate this I hate this I'm telling y'all
there's a reason that me the crazy dude
who shows you guys
everything did not show you
this I just learned it airport a
[Music]
Lobby sitting amongst what like 10
people in a
airport it's
coughing people are starting to
move oh my god
dude people are
moving two two people are getting up and
moving
just trying to live these last
moments holy
I need to charge too dude he just
cleared out like seven
people that's actually
pretty oh the guy behind him
leaving which way is the um which way oh
I don't know who this guy is but he's he
he just sent his his buddy in there too
to do some Ops fresh fade though sick
fade true true I think these prank humor
kind of outdated I mean listen it was
dated this stuff has always been
dated it arrived
expired the right what happened oh
the that's that's crazy oh my God wait
was that did he let me go back cuz I
wasn't I was reading
[Music]
chat which way is the um which no the no
what the right what
[Music]
happened he's CH so a guy and his
daughter walking through the airport and
he's he coughs and the dude's like yo
what the hell and he walks away and then
this guy chases he kind of chases him
down and keeps
coughing uh y'all wanted this don't be
mad at me who wanted this again people
have been clamoring for this Dan what do
you mean who well I showed a subreddit
with 600 points okay so people
remember he didn't cough on the kid he
coughed in their Direction say that but
it these are actors I'm
I'm we it's time to get
cancelled
[Music]
oh
come on man you don't want to help
excuse me you know where the car rentals
is huh
downstairs how do you get there from
here off man don't cough around me
all right downstairs go
downstairs what the wrong with
you downstairs and where you being
stupid or something
yeah I mean it's crazy right it's nuts
and uh good thing it never
happened it's a good thing they're all
actors don't you guys
[Applause]
think um let's keep going we're almost
there AB you love this right this
sketch I'm I'm I'm laughing yeah I'm
seeing not everyone in the audience is
loving it but
this is if you don't like it then you
first of all we have chapters you can
skip ahead but then you know also this
is important this is
historic Lena your
thoughts same as ABS I mean I laughed
but I know it's yeah I get it it's okay
to laugh it's a
sketch what you from where you from
Israel oh nice you I visit there a lot
Israel where yeah I love it over there I
go to Tel Aviv you know around
there I'm from the h of Brooklyn rud in
New York City he so wild know it's at I
think he he invented like NPC meme
before it was popular yeah he he has
always been a Trailblazer like I'm being
straight up the Elsa Spider-Man Elsa
stuff those were on that pranks in the
hood I mean as shitty as that was
they were Trailblazers MH uh in that as
well you know and now
this yeah I know the people watching
live can't skip ahead but this is
historic you guys were here when it
[Music]
happened they wait to get there go
downstairs
[Music]
make all thanks man
you can you cannot sh I don't like this
guy as much you don't know that there's
a virus what kind of virus yeah
sh on where I'm from with shake hands
bro I Shakeen too but no I
can't this is psychotic
why I can't s man you your hand all
right left hand man thank
you yeah he's at he's at a airport
Kos putting in his info excuse
me a little
bit wait wasn't there one in like a dut
shop you just confusing it with the
infamous Ethan Bradberry donut video Oh
I thought he sent us one of him in a dut
shop I guess not that I remember
I'm from the you got to grab that Zach
I'm from the heart of
Brooklyn you know that's a good
[Music]
bite
yeah I mean good thing it's not
real CU if it
was why is he still filming huh why is
it still filming save some buttery man
cuz I have to tell him to stop huh I
have to tell him to stop
why does this guy not walk away you know
what I'm saying I have to something to
stop for him to
stop this dude is wild he just w't walk
away all right we're good oh okay so
there it is where we made it through
good job everybody good
job we all did
it there it is yes you know I mean Ethan
are you willing to release the Bradberry
Co video now that enough time has passed
you know so what what you asked for so
let's do a PLL did we love it yes okay
sure let's do a poll yeah I'm
curious I I think you're underestimated
I think most people enjoyed it yeah
people probably 70% enjoyed it people
probably liked that we showed it but
they didn't enjoy the video and by the
way yeah did you enjoy that I showed it
and I'm not saying did you like the
video it's more than that it's more than
that right it's more than a bad poll
then cuz it doesn't work did we love the
video well hold on it's just cuz no one
probably loved the video it's not about
loving the video it's about the
experience that we all shared
together I I love the experience dude
what the dude y'all are
lame 58% no like come on you
guys that's I blame ab and Lena because
I was ready to move on but AB was like I
love this I said okay I'll do it for
him I was ready to leave it quickly
Olivia what were your thoughts that's
what I get for trying to back you up I
hated that video garbage well
will you say that now well and I was
trying to back you up you're my boy I
wanted you to you know what' you think
Olivia uh I don't don't be nice he'll
just betray you I just kept thinking
about like I would never betray Olivia
oh my God thank you I'm a girl girl
you're my girl no absolutely I just kept
imagining like how the people around
them must have felt in that moment
because I just we were so freaked out at
that time if that had taken place at
that time obviously if the sketch was
real which it's not right yeah I mean if
someone did that next to me during that
time I would have freaked the out
the most paranoid I Know Dan so that's
why I'm saying if I can laugh about it
then so can you you
know but anyway that was for ab I'm glad
you enjoyed it
AB
I'm really happy you enjoyed that we had
we shared that that moment together all
right so the poll is pretty much done we
have 9,000 votes F oh H it's bouncing
around a little bit 54% said no we do
not like
it 46% said yes
so the people are split we only wasted
um
30,000 of y'all's 7 minutes of your life
no 15,000 15,000 right 54% anyway there
it is that's it we can memory hold that
now we never have to think about it
again please thank God do you think it'd
be worth sending Ethan Bradberry back
out now that there's not a p you know
like he's not going to commit crimes
necessarily doing interviews of people
do you think he pushed it too hard too
fast he slam you're asking if we should
send him around to ask people about Co
right now no no no just about whatever
to an event just man on the
street perhaps I don't know if he's in
the game anymore you know I haven't he
would answer the call rry content in a
long time he hasn't posted on YouTube
for he comments on every single post of
ela's I'm pretty sure oh does he on
Instagram yeah okay just like slamming
or something hell
yeah all
right maybe something with uh Ethan and
jimmmy Lee
oh dude two different Generations hold
the phone Jimmy's in town same person
low key Jimmy's on ice this is a good
segue
Jimmy yeah okay
so Jimmy's in town today he's doing
Bobby Lee's podcast which I'm very
excited to watch and I hope Bobby
doesn't get mad at
me because he's doing me a personal
favor having Jimmy
on but I think if he can survive a
podcast with Bobby Lee I think he might
have a have a future as a as an
Entertainer he's on Joe Rogan next week
probably I heard he's going back on Hoy
yeah he's going back on hoe but we we
took a
vote cuz you know we we in and out with
Jimmy
so I asked the
crew to everybody place a vote if we
should bring them back or not
and um the results
were at first the results were
resounding yes frankly and I and I'm
even going to throw you guys some
curveballs Sam voted yes Zach voted yes
Zach I changed my vote I know well well
so there something happened changed my
vote we yeah something happened later
who else voted yes love you did yeah I
voted yes I didn't change my vote Dan
voted yes there's only three NOS no I
didn't know I didn't voted
no I voted instantly what cam I was the
first no oh you were no oh okay maybe
cam was the and then I think even ab and
oh you guys abstained right AB and Lena
yeah they abstained seemed like his
discussion was already
over so at first it was like okay
Jimmy's coming in but something happened
and I don't know how to describe it to
you guys in a way that makes sense but
he he did something
he did something and we all pretty much
switched to no after that
went against the family go against the
family yeah that was pretty bad after
everything I've done for
you you come out to my city Los Angeles
you go against the
family this kind of disrespect I can't
understand enough with the tomatoes
shoot the son of a although I
don't hate the idea of Jimmy and eth and
Bradberry I kind of love that pairing
mhm send him into send him out to like
uh times uh Time Square Time Square or
or uh the park you
know just let him go maybe some kind of
convention or something they might be
good at they're both on the East Coast
too I mean this might be a
pairing so yeah I mean is there anything
else to say about it so he's out he's on
Ice he's back on ice
he's on a deep freeze right now dentist
on knives
[Music]
mhm people want the tea there's no tea
trust me
it's it's
not it's not something to talk about
people want the spill a te gu let's do a
pull Dan do we want Jimmy Leon yes or no
I'm curious what the audience thinks we
we'll spill the T in two years same with
the BR be four I don't know if that'll
be enough time frankly it depends
all
right yeah it's pretty fresh chocolate
mocha you know um do we want Jimmy Leon
yes or no get your votes in I'm curious
no I mean it's a
clear early
lead oh man
Jimmy you are your approval rating is
low
man 57% saying no to Jimmy Lee 58%
man just oversaturated last year darn Oh
shoot what a bummer damn Dan is
devastated to hear that all right well
there it is Jimmy Lee's on ice but I do
look do you look forward to the Bobby
Lee podcast
mhm um little bit I'm very excited I
kind of I I I'm kind of stressed about
it to be honest in what in what way
because we like sicked poor Bobby with
with Jimmy like why did we do that to
him well no he went around us well no it
he wouldn't have had a foot in the door
if it wasn't for us what do you mean he
went around us we were we didn't
schedule this yeah we didn't oh but like
we introduced them and I said Bobby do
me a personal favor and get Jimmy on oh
I texted him live on the show I said Do
me a personal favor and get this guy
Jimmy Lee on I'm just he he instead of
booking through us he just like said
it and then went directly to that's
fine I mean frankly it's F frankly
that's better because we don't have to
deal with his flaky
weirdness all right you guys want to
know what Cav Cav's been up to he posted
um he posted a clip on his Instagram
called I think so he from what I can
understand this has been deleted
although it's been widely reported that
this was posted on his Instagram
page so from from uh on the street on
the ground reporting we believe this to
be
true
allegedly he posted a clip called The
Real Housewives of
Hamas uh and it's it features jokes like
one of them comes out with a suicide
vest on and she's like do you guys love
it oh man where' you get and then and
then her friend comes out with the same
suicide vest on they're like hey she's
like oh it makes you you stole my
outfit pry bad also it uh was we
discovered it was from a BBC show from
2017 and it it was uh Real Housewives of
Isis not Hamas so they just slapped the
new uh title on right it that blows my
mind frankly that BBC did that hey suck
D's balls I guess they thought it's Isis
we can say whatever we want and didn't
think about it as like insulting to uh
Muslims at large although I mean I feel
like since 911 no one's given a to
just on us yeah I think it's just
it's kind of worldwide you think so
don't you think like recently in the
past like five or 10 years people I mean
2017 is definitely when it was
becoming well and I'm sure it was
probably pretty controversial at the
time when I looked it up there was like
a bunch of Articles from then of them
getting Flack for it and stuff so it was
definitely edgy is wild that would be
wild at any time right yeah it was super
racist but cavc is posting that
so we love that about him I'd love to
show you guys the clip but uh it got
claimed by
BBC they have not disavowed it they yeah
they still they claim that they own that
not only do we proudly stand behind this
piece of content right we reserve the
right to earn money and to claim anybody
that reuses our tremendous original cont
[Music]
in a
box oh boy also another C Cavs if you
type his name into Google or whatever
search engine you use does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey Weinstein
don't type that just type his name wait
look on Google whoa he took there it is
it's linked to his account offal sh okay
good so it is so we just definitely
confirmed confirmed let me click this
but I think it he took it down or
something but it's like still in the a
yes dude you're busted dude oh C's got
1.2 million it's a it's a race between
him and Jimmy Lee thank you I wonder if
he has a huge Brazilian fan
base oh he here's a post oh my God look
at this post from September 1st 20123
it's finally coming oh can we go to the
premiere we should go to the
Premier we got to go this insanely bad
night night it's literally the law
suit's sexiest night well they don't
have a date still I mean this was
from September of last year it's
like almost half a year now what year is
is it supposed to be soon I thought I
thought it came out in February
supposedly skill skill still
in you know it's still Ting Up release
February 2024 oh my God oh my God oh my
God it's almost
it's almost but there's not a date still
dude still not a date just
February can you imagine if I just
bootle his and he has to sue me
again
for M stream on I just want to be with
you forever cuz Frank Frankly I think
that I could watch an entire movie and
and with the critical uh commentary that
well for sure deliver it would for sure
be fair use frankly something that
hasn't been tested really like a whole
movie reaction I might be open to that
frankly not the um like the rift tracks
and like Mystery Science Theater guys
get away with that somehow the on the
old show was all public domain stuff but
they do like modern ones now so what I
understand is they get permission
although technically we think they would
they don't have to Bryce will give us
permission yes I don't believe it's he
probably does not own the uh you don't
think he's got a EP credit on
there um so I'm going to talk to my
lawyer and see but I I'd be open to
watching the whole movie that'd be
nuts definitely got sued right but I
feel like you're will take that fight on
I feel like it'd be an easy dub that's
that's your call fair use
baby when is this movie come out I
cannot find a release date so what I was
going to say is this horrible this
disgusting poster that looks like Ryan
made it himself look at the there's it's
so dark why is it so dark and these
blood spatters I mean this is just
horrible giveaway this got 113,000 likes
great
so the world is
waiting we need to see
this uh we can't wait to see this movie
oh it's the same guy twice here's Bryce
Hall portal
[Music]
and then
here's Bryce I've been sucked into the
Bryce Hall portal he commented twice
that's so
interesting and actually it's written a
little different we need to see this and
then again we can't wait to see this
movie thanks for taking care of her bro
I love horror movies Talia said it's a
private account unfortunately so would
love to see this uh Jenna said listen to
this Rift tracks used to just sell their
own commentary audio with no video it
starts with a countdown you have to
press play at the to match their audio
so that would be a way that we could
do like an accompanying but then people
are going to have to buy and like right
fine there the thing is if I'm doing
critical
commentary doesn't require people to pay
for this movie
interesting
interesting that would be so good though
if I did do that he'd for sure sue me
like I I know that he will I'll talk to
my lawyer see what he thinks
if he thinks it's like an easy dub then
I really don't
mind I mean good call at this point just
throw it in the pile I'm sure your your
lawyer will definitely say yes oh God
yeah we should take this song Let Go
yeah dude his grandparent his great
grandchildren are going to
college I'm telling
you so anyway what was I saying type in
Ryan Kavanagh into Google MH and then
which I was delighted to see that they
still
cashed this super racist islamophobic
nightmare of a post he
did shame on you Ryan
awful shame on you man yep how dare
you not now not ever oh we went
down a lot I mean it's back up we're
popping back up one or two like last
night I looked it was number three yeah
it's going to be back up tomorrow H well
I recommend everyone click it and just
brush up on your knowledge if you search
on Ryan kav a podcast if you search that
in Google yeah also Ryan cavana
podcast oh good we're number one no
we're not Apple's number one you're
we're number one for me number two for
you it it jumps up and down Apple wait
this metadata is not very good it should
say failure podcast shouldn't it oh it's
weird
it says that for me I cuz here it just
says Ryan Kavanaugh articles d r k l l h
w I don't know why it's like that for
you it's not that's not the sear result
I got and this guy how has the
failure podcast still not released any
episodes he's dedicated I'm so upset
dude he's true to his word he's
committed to the biit being a
failure it was supposed to come out in
December it's almost February it'll come
out with a grind house steel house Ste
whatever this guy can't release
anything can release his hands of all
his investors money which is he what he
said we're number one on
Bing is that true actually because
that's kind of Epic yeah because Bing's
legit they know what the is up I
think we we knew have let's see thank
you yo number one yeah okay here is um
here he is with so he he filmed it he
even got got director chairs bro you're
not a director anymore the movie has
supposedly been done for a while was the
podcast your podcast he's got props and
too dude he got the director chair
what an bro you're not in the
industry you got to retire started when
I was pretty young I think I was running
the studio when I was 25 and so I was
arguably called the most powerful person
in Hollywood for about 10 years I think
I was doing like 40 movies a year and TV
shows and so during that period of time
you know I was around
thought he was the most powerful person
in Hollywood like pretty much every
studio and that's during Harvey
Weinstein's reign of
terror pretty much right so uh it was in
that same era
yeah um structured kind of created
Marvel Studios and um so I was like dud
the mumbling I create sort of created
Marvel Studios wow the first time for me
on the failure
podcast this is the first time
uh he says exciting times on the failure
podcast as we welcome legendary Chris
Johnson a master trainer with who's no
stranger to the elite Chris has worked
with the likes of LeBron Dwayne Johnson
Wade uh R Rondo raan Rondo a trusted
consultant for top sports okay all right
uh I love this cool why we listen to it
look at look this photo look at the
failure in the background look at the
sign like what is this is that a real
sign like what I thought it was a
watermark at first I is that a neon sign
NE broad daylight daylight
outside just kind of hanging there also
like is he trying to flex on his
backyard like failure but also check me
out the world well that's why I'm
confused by the sign because if it's
like the whole thing was on theme of
like a shitty sign and being a up
but then he's trying to show off his
backyard so hold on what is this this
looks like a menu it's probably a script
you think that's a script bro you're not
supposed to script
podcast man so who's this guy is this
guy actually somebody famous Chris
Johnson hashtag master trainer hashtag
Chris Johnson
nothing careful scrolling through random
hashtag yeah yeah
yeah God there's this phenomenon
where I just I had my tags open forever
cuz I don't really with the
settings on Instagram I don't check DMs
I don't do anything there and recently I
just randomly went at my tagged
um Tab and if you go there it's just
endless endless amounts of porn that's
just tagged as like adverts and I've
noticed these companies are doing it to
like any celebrity or largely followed
account tag your account and then so
it's just advertising for their porn and
so I turned off tagging and I started to
do erase them and after like 15 minutes
I I I gave up cuz there's like literally
a thousand so on your page you see it
yeah see I at first it just looks clean
so that's probably where you kind of the
bad ones and then like when you get 10
pages down it's just poor yeah yeah yeah
so I cleared the top of it but I turned
off tagging
so isn't that crazy that's awesome like
they haven't figured that out I noticed
that probably when you turn it off
shouldn't the tab disappear that's what
I thought would happen right but
no Ethan you're on my close friends list
okay thank you
congratulations I have not probably seen
your
stories I don't have a friend I don't
even have a close friends list if you
can believe that oh really you don't
have a top eight girl I don't he's lying
he has one us are I would you guys would
be on it if I had it you wouldn't put us
in in your circle I mean I get really
flattered when people invite me to
theirs really I invite you to my close
friend's story did I accept absolutely
that's not something you do you don't
accept you just are put on there was
some there was some really nice people
who I like and respect who added me to
their friend Circle and it made me it
was very nice that's cool yeah it was
very nice oh yeah yeah Dan would we be
on
yours I think I have one so that answers
your question I think I know I'm
not my tag page is lovely it's all very
nice sweet
people maybe because your account's a
lot
bigger uh
anyway I didn't I didn't hear a word you
said a you're just doing
the I you not found the close
friends thing and I just opened it I
didn't touch anything look at who the
first person oh my God he added I'm the
most recent ad and I and I believe you
that you just clicked it no I didn't
just do it just now that's no I know I
believe you okay so she is on your list
yeah and what about
me damn ela's on
there okay yeah uh I see Ela I'll see it
through hers Dan I'll W I'll be watching
uh let me see
you better behave on that I'll be
watching wait is Ela really on here and
you're not oh no there you are you're
you're on oh thank God he was one of the
first people you added I bet that would
it go in in order like that okay got it
oh thank you Dan I just want to point
out in that post ccabs W in some very
expensive shoes okay I love that you
know that stuff let me pull it up let me
go back to it um he really is
such an over compensator so what are
these sneakers they appear to be Nike SB
they called the yellow
lobsters uh they go for about 45 Yellow
Monsters on the red monsters they go for
45 what 45 Grand 100 Grand depending on
wait are you serious Google
yellow lobsters um wait if you have a
$100,000 pair of shoes you wouldn't wear
them would you I don't know maybe
they're gifted to them you would like
although they do look a little off um
because the yellow lobsters have like
this splattering on them I don't know if
the camera is just not picking it up or
something but um I can't imagine you'd
wear those if you if that's what they
were they look like yellow lobsters what
about this red white pattern is that
part of it that's like the lobster so
like oh
yeah here's stock X Nike
Dunks uh the
lobster like they have orange Lobster
Red Lobsters let's take a look this is
going for 42,000 last sale was 42,000
holy
dude I didn't know snik I didn't
know you they were
even I didn't know sneakers run that
high oh yeah it's kind of insane
so let me see do we think that that's it
I guess what's throwing me off is the
splatter or maybe just the cameras not I
think it doesn't have the pixels yeah
that certainly look I mean that's either
it or a fake
yeah I think that's it what a psycho why
would you wear those you shouldn't wear
those failure ass dumbass
loser
your money didn't make you keep
your wife with you I'll tell you
that money can't buy love or respect mhm
can buy nice shoe or success or success
right I mean that kind of just fell into
your lap just ordered my gamer sub using
Code H3 however I don't have a cup to
put it in when H3 Cup coming out I don't
know I just asked thank you Chris by the
way for the Don appreciate that okay I'm
I'm sorry if I missed this if we talked
about already but we have did you guys
mention the other hand in the photo what
other hand in the photo oh my God the
one I just had open oh what the
look at this okay let me re is this
people are saying is this AI
generated what okay where's the hand
look zoom in oh zoom in to his left sh
left oh that's I think that's just wait
hold on is that just the chair a hand
behind it they
edit what the
Ryan what is wrong with you shoes
are
fake photoshops his guest is
fake he's hash no he's
hash Chris Johnson can we reverse image
shirts just Chris johnon Johnson maybe
it's taken from a different photo why
the would he
what dude somehow this man is so
incompetent that took my breath away he
can't even post a I've chills a
photograph without it up that
doesn't look like his hand either that
looks like beta there's a tattoo on that
hand are you serious you know what they
must have photoshopped someone out in
the background yeah cuz kind of look at
the background it looks a little bit
weird no under his elbow
y right it's getting old dude it does
like that those rock this looks odd yeah
and this guy that's so fun wait
this does look his whole and look at his
forearm this whole thing looks
photoshopped yeah yeah it is weird
something's off here look at um the
failure chair like go zoom in does that
area look weird too like it's little off
colored there m that one looks okay no
look at the watch there there's like a
the watch yeah yeah no Cam's right I see
it oh what is no Cam's right oh here
down here what is that I wish that we
could get
closer what is that I mean it looks like
brick
but nothing else is that color and it
kind of like Blends into his hold on
hold on you guys where's his
Shadow well there's no Shadow the man
doesn't have a shadow no the other way
the sun is too low the sun is super low
has a shadow yeah it it looks like that
shadow is stretched
out interesting it's hard he's blocking
the sun Cav
Cav oh Jesus now look at it look at it
now looks like the dude is a
photoshopped into the P weird like that
dude was just placed in there we need
some expert copy pasted in what the
you are right that's that shadow is
doesn't look real cuz the Shadow
from that is like the sun would be so
low to stretch it out that
way that is so doesn't make sense well
the sun would have to be behind
them pretty low behind them right but
it's not in not in so it's it have to be
above
there yeah it could cast there's no
shadow cast from this that doesn't make
sense would be here look at his shadow
too yeah he has a shadow but that's like
a weird ass shadow that doesn't make
sense either yeah his Shadow is also
Shadow also does not make sense true now
everything looks fake look how this is
edited the move like this is cut weird
on the
front this is fake
what an
idiot this guy sucks at
everything you know life is so up
like Society is so sick that this man is
so rich
and uh enjoys so much wealth yeah he he
really is a symptom isn't he well being
not he's not just not talented the man
is incompetent every single facet of
living yeah the talents suck it's a
black hole of Charisma and
talent what the man what is
this can we get any closer we're 100%
sure that's a hand I mean I think it
looks like a hand
but
on Photoshop it's definitely a hand okay
look at Ryan's other hand look at his if
you could zoom in as much as possible
that's all I got okay where's his thumb
it oh it's down here yeah yeah but some
it looks like there was another finger
that's cut off on the other
end all the way at the end there's a
little this yeah what is that this here
no that's his thumb no no other side of
this no no other other side of his hand
his pink same pinky side pinky yeah it
looks like there should be a finger
there I don't see it I think it's just
kind of the Skins fold in I see what you
mean but yeah he's got some flabby
hands but then if you look at that hand
compared to the other hand it's two
different Hands Chris Johnson let me
look up this guy if he's
real Johnson he's a CO what is he a
coach coach I I reversed image search
the
faces let's see Johnson has specifically
worked with over 40 NBA players such as
LeBron James that's what he
so what are you trying to say about this
guy by inviting him in on your podcast
called
failure it's a little that's not exactly
a compliment to the guy who by all means
seems to have lived a successful uh life
and
career you
know okay hold on somebody okay
somebody's claiming something I need to
look into it but if this is true this
will this will be a great great fine
they also made Ryan kav skin here for
sure look at that Instagram post I just
sent there's no
way um well I mean it's just that's not
the same person really in my opinion why
does it look so low quality hell
here what's the time difference from
this post to oh my sorry sorry sorry
sorry I'm sorry I should have warned you
wait this is
September it's a couple months ago
obviously but and then this one is
from December so I mean it's a couple
months
but I mean I have nothing to say about
his weight I'm just saying that they're
suspicious not just his weight I mean
everything
yeah like geez
[Music]
dude I mean I'm not one to talk because
I I used to look like this too frankly
sure it's just more that the video the
image is altered
you
know God damn though yeah he looks a lot
fresher hair maybe he got freshened up
in those two
months didn't look like it judging on
that and Dan you got a breaking you have
a break development I had to log in to
be able to view
it we have some kind investigating we
have some kind of Breaking Stand stand
by well this is exciting investigation
impr
progis big news oh boy oh boy all right
well I've pretty much this is big news
I've talked as much as I possibly can
about Cav
Cav um with the exception of what Dan's
working on could you talk about gamer
subs and how they're the sponsor today's
episode IDE actually could you talk
about that I love gamer sub Nation
everybody rise up rise up get up Gamers
rise the up stand up that's very
good cuz Sigma brain is back in stock Fu
my
friends let me get a whiff of this
clean can I snort this or
no uh no don't do that don't snort it
it's a drink it's a
drink I don't know I just like it a lot
I just really like it but I wouldn't do
that oh yeah very good let's go right
now dude that's really
good listen to this keto friendly neut
tropic
[Music]
sugarfree bustling with caffeine or
non-caffeine version this is the one
drink you need and we even saw they use
it in
preworkout mhm you know that means it's
quite versatile it's hydrating it's
energizing it gives you the electrolytes
you need guys it has 4,
187% of your daily B12
needs that's a lot of B12 that is a lot
of B12 that's very
good um it tastes amazing yeah we get it
the sigma brain it's a little spicy you
know but in a good way and and I promise
you I have to emphasize this if you're
adverse to spicy foods you will still
like this you will still like this and
that's my guarantee that's a cash back
guarantee on behalf of gamer Subs I
don't I don't think that that is
actually a guarantee I'm making the
guarantee right now on behalf of all of
us here at the H podcast and gamer
Subs they probably have legally I don't
know if you can do that on behalf of
Gamers probably not this I have not
discussed I have not discussed it with
them right I'll just say
that um but I'm telling you this is you
scoop it in your drink you shake it up
and there's so many servings in one of
these the value is nuts it's like what
25 cents per her drink or something even
less yeah maybe even less
yeah um it really is
phenomenal absolutely recommend it I
love gamer subs and I've been on it for
a long time I mean here at the office we
all sip in it every day that's very good
and a big tip that I always do I keep
like small water bottles in my fridge
take one out pop some powder in there
boom Oh cold water yeah cold water and
just water bottles pop one in boom shake
it up and leave oh perfect snack on the
go or drink on the go it's so simple
that's smart yeah yeah guys check it out
code H3 will go from 10 it usually gets
you 10% off right now you're going to
get 22% off starting this
Friday for 7 Days that's 22% off with
code H3 22 baby um get a fat discount on
your Sigma brain it's back in stock
that's really
good and uh go to gamersupps.gg and use
the code H3 to get 22% off your order
starting this Friday one more time gamer
subs. G use the code H3 for 22% off
starting this Friday thank you to gamer
Subs we love them and uh we're thankful
for their
support so thank
[Applause]
you okay I got I got something too all
right what do we got I'm live have big
news I'm excited okay go ahead all right
you
ready whoa wait what is this this is the
original photo who are these people what
the is happening bro what did you
why did you do this why did you remove
them stalling hold on hold on zoom in
zoom in I got I can you send me the
photo cuz I need to look at this like
really closely yeah Del here
oh my God man you are such a
weirdo so if you look in the original
too uh that he posted or not the
original I guess but the one that capc
posted you could see the tiles are
doubled uh where they cut these people
out you know that games my boys play it
where it's like Spot the Difference yeah
so let's play that it's a really good
edit to be fair except the hand big
mistake difference Astron would never
left the hand never
y'all forgot the
hand did you forget a hand firstand
that's amazing work think
so I don't know what do you think cam
it's not that impressive is it not
really yeah could you me a favorite cam
put these next to each other so I can
easily view them both side by side one
firstand so who are these guys he cut
out cuz I would be a little bit offended
if I was them I mean
clearly uh well one of them is uh the
person who posted this photo um that we
discovered it on I had to come cover for
Ian but Olivia do you still have that
person's um yeah his name is Jack Levy
maybe just sent because I don't want to
uh send his whole profile but could you
just send the text in his post or
something oh yeah yeah yeah here I'll
send the link cuz he he apparently is
involved in the making of This
podcast do they have cut out like I
Wonder has there been some kind of
falling out because
oh that's
awesome because not the podcast like the
famous Stalin
photograph let's all right let's see the
podcast has not come out and he's
photoshopping his his producers out his
producers out like what has happened
back there I mean there was a
catastrophic failure let's see it's a
good
point
dude Ryan you can't get anything past
this boy I'll tell guy fing guy so you
spotted it right this part is
photoshopped and it looks weird as
the hand so it looks like maybe the
shadow was not
edited slightly remove the Shadows from
the other people it looks
like um he he I don't think they made
him skinnier they color graded him a
little bit seems like they made him a
little redder yeah you don't need to be
more red look at his face he looks more
c c
[Music]
you're a weirdo
bro man out of all the billionaires to
sue you we really did get lucky I don't
think any of them are this goofy weirdo
bro yeah this one is funny also publicly
goofy
right all the all the people who used to
be the most powerful self-proclaimed
people in Hollywood he's the best he is
the best you're
right you're right oh there's like even
hold on there's even like
um there's like dining tables back here
for like catering that they remove too
you see that he may have used uh some AI
tool to remove them this yeah this looks
like adobe's like beta AI Photoshop for
real like you Circle and you're like
remove these two people beta he doesn't
know how to do that he paid someone and
got he paid someone for work they
took they took him for all he's got
can I Moonlight for him do a better job
you know what that would be really nice
cam yeah do a really clean One beta and
I'll ask I'll send it to my lawyer and
ask him to send it over it's
inappropriate to contact him
directly um chachy BT said upon closer
inspection of the image there's indeed
an additional hand on the left guy's
shoulder wait they can analyze photos
now yeah but he didn't catch it at first
I had to ask
is there an extra hand on the left side
there and then he realized he didn't
realize okay this could be an indication
of photo manipulation or could simply be
someone else's hand who was standing
behind or to the side out of frame okay
come on wrong dumb ass firstand yeah
make a really nice clean
one that's
exciting I'm thrilled for him his
podcast seems to be going
great
oh this is so okay this is how you make
somebody care about your podcast all
right so the guy who posted
this yeah check us out now that's now
that's pure joy look at the Shadows even
Shadows even the Shadows a little
slapstick but look at the Shadows man
it's a little slap together but I did it
fast so did it very fast that podcast is
called success yeah that's the winning
one true and you're all invited oh my
God I'm
there man what an idiot could talk about
this so much like it doesn't get
old it's
great all right well we love
them we kid him because we love him and
we're all rooting for you
Ryan congratulations To Love Oh wait
no hold on I got to go back I'm not
done talking about
so the guy who posted this
photo um wrote this description about it
yeah one of the dudes in the photo he
said hey folks incredible news run a
Unstoppable role shooting episode three
of failure was an absolute blast
alongside the super producer Ryan kavana
and our amazing guest NBA vet and super
coach Chris Johnson Chris oh he's a game
changer
folks coaching the top 1% including the
one and only LeBron James and now he's
bringing that winning style to
Executives and anyone hungry for Success
the
is this just some multi-level
marketing all of a
sudden coaching the top
1% now he's bringing it to Executives
executive and anyone hungry for Success
well maybe they just mean in he's
sharing his insights on the podcast
sounds like he's
selling I guess we'll have to tune in
and find
out this guy's the key to unlocking
motivation and success without a hint of
excuses trust me it's mind-blowing stay
tuned later this month to witness the
pure magic that Chris and Chris and Ryan
are about to unleash get ready for some
seriously in Inspiration oh man
everybody's waiting here's the link let
me click on it oh and there's nothing
there it's not right to keep people
waiting
H let's got get this to the people all
right let's move on let moving
on love got your citizen ship card yeah
that happened fast congratulations man
oh Costco
yeah congratulations You' been in there
yeah dude I went there yesterday with
did you got a hot dog and all that got a
hot dog Pizza everything wow the deals
are crazy right dude I walked out there
with a whole card of groceries I was
like it's going to be like 600
bucks or some crazy 250 bucks boom
insane boom congratulations cost
congratulations it is nuts I love it
it's a great company actually they they
apparently are great employers too oh
really mhm and I dude I was just
laughing walking around there cuz you
you can like change your tires there too
fill up your gas there's nowhere else
where you could buy like 10 gallons of
mayonnaise in one container I don't know
I just giggling all all the way I love
it do you need 1,000 rolls of toilet
paper yeah Costco baby
mhm um
we got more J Shetty beef holy
so apparently the try guys were up
for an award miles Bolan I don't know
what his last name is Bon singer it's
Bolan um listen to this odd
story
okay
oops remember I told everyone to vote
great about it is that I won the
listeners award I have a signal
yeah but remember I told everyone
to vote for me and I was like vote for
the signal and it was so clear that I
won by a landslide and they gave me
Silver and a little thing that was like
listener's Choice silver we don't know
what the silver gold and bronze means
but we have one of each and then they
gave the award to some other guy
you hear that J shett you can
eat my ass let's go let's take a moment
to actually really reflect on what's
being said here this man said he
brigaded the voting and he was sure he
crushed it number one growth J
Shetty has some kind of arrangement with
these people where he's why is he
winning every award by the way that
alone is suspicious like I don't know
what the even this award is and
he's out there winning it it doesn't
make sense to
me there's really something nefarious
going on behind those
eyes you don't know what it's like at
the very least his team is incred at
submitting him for awards like they hit
so many just like he's always
featured you know I got to start
entering yeah we can enter you nobody
respects me that's the thing I respect
you that's the signal are you voting are
you voting on any of these bodies no
they're not they're not worth it I got
to get my people in you know how like
Trump he like got all his people into
the local voting yeah I got to do that
with my people so I can start winning
Awards that's what Jay
does this is years in the making youall
wonder why he just popped up like a year
ago now he's everywhere this is years in
the
[Music]
making going to this
commission oh I found some dirt on one
of your members voting members be a
shame if he had to resign in disgrace oh
by the way let me introduce you to this
super
Talent
Harvard
grad podcast uh
afficianado 20-in dick by
growth actually if you go to this
website uh for Signal
Awards it has like a fee it seems oh for
real this say entry deadlines and fees
huh that's corny as the one an
award you have to pay for entries that
contain pornographic material serial
propagate hate message or make
defamatory statements that are otherwise
extraordinarily offensive are not only
uncool they are also not eligible to win
a signal award why would they be what
does that even
mean
what don't you just write someone's
name by growth just a I'm just going to
write a defamatory statement here as an
entry um all all right oh here's the
fees yeah early entry
deadline 265 bucks individual episode
225 branded shows and ads get a little
premium there 275 professional plan so
this is what Shetty bought for
sure you go professional plan
$800 what is this win the Winner's
bundle do you guys do you guys know
about this what is this award
800 then here's the asteris at the
bottom it says to diversify the entries
and celebrate our love of listening we
have introduced a suite of categories
that focus on those idiosyncratic things
that make us love
podcasts all love of listening
categories can be entered for 125 before
early entry deadline that that's
shady
what the by the way entry fees are
non-refundable should we
enter there's a Winner's Gallery at the
Top If you want to see who you're up
against yeah if you want to take a look
at the type of people usually winning
this it might uh let's see SC your
decision a little bit more I got to
close this pop up okay so J shett
scumbag 2023 dude this this is the
dumbest this is the most obvious
mind like are you telling me
that yeah nobody's listening to Kevin
Hart's podcast nobody that might not be
true but also why are all the winners
like like these mainstream like listen I
love Seinfeld and I love Julia Dr fist
or whatever the she's not she
doesn't have the best podcast I'm sure
of it I I have to I'm I got to defend
that one it's pretty good wiser than me
you listen to that you listen to wiser
than me me and seant tall will put it on
every okay
is it the best podcast no this is but um
we're more than a podcast is it
Innovative is it funny does it have a a
a Ensemble of interesting characters no
but she does interview some some
interesting people is it like if your
aunt had a podcast type thing my aunt
yeah I mean like is it like just homie
Vibes sure yeah I hate my aunt but yeah
you know go that did you listen to the
uh the Fran libowitz
episode I did not listen you listen to
the Jane Fonda I listen to the Jane
Fonda episode you did
okay oh yeah well there's only uh did
you know Snoop Dog has a uh podcast I
didn't I don't think anyone did I did
not know that I mean listen shout out
Snoop Dogg for all you do but you're not
you know nobody's listening to that for
everything everything you
do do in everything the thing is podcast
is like it's a different type of media
to break into it doesn't matter how
famous you are because it's
like I feel the only way you've learned
about podcasts is through Word of Mouth
you can't get people watching a podcast
because it's you don't see it from I
mean ours is visual but I think every
single other one pretty much is in
recent years I've started to see like
Billboards for some of the bigger ones
yeah and they're all being paid for by
Spotify basically exclusively for for
people they're buying I mean think the
market is definitely flooded right now
for podcast you know it has been it's
absolutely bananas but it's so hard to
recommend to people too it's not like a
movie or anything you can't like yeah
you can't be in a car with your friends
and introduce them to a podcast too
right you know what I mean it's like
Kevin Hart yeah he's one of the biggest
comedians but that doesn't mean
anybody's listening to
this
maybe I'm I mean doubt Kevin I heard
he's on triller
though did you I read that in
description that he's on triller I think
they maybe caught some Flack for that
because I didn't they had to remove that
does does he have an account I'm on
triller right now let me take a look
Kevin
Hart um H doesn't pop up with any hey
suck de balls wait Kevin Hart for
real oh he's on he's on real for for
real for real with two L's ow weird he
um he only has 142 followers
maybe it's not for real 142 followers
yeah but what's be real have to do with
triller nothing with be real for
real
oh it's still okay so yeah he's
confirmed on here that must have been
what they were talking about this must
be
him that's him it's Kevin har for real
okay so here's the signal Awards I have
2,000 followers
on Instagram let's see Snoop Dogg see
he's a big winner let check it out
should we check turn off the oh true we
haven't checked this bro these people
really going to come for me you know
they will
now on
purpose bro I don't listen I don't want
to be in any category bir opra by the
way I was going to say literally 70 she
just turned 70 the big 70 no offense to
OA no offense to Oprah but I don't want
to be in any category of award where
she's also in
it why wouldn't you want to be in the
same Echelon as opra because everything
she it's it's all cauliflower she she is
the human embodiment of cauliflower
crust wait tell me more that's
interesting it's all marketing I get
exactly it's all Sheen I mean you're
right it's all oist but you're right
there on the shelf and and Sons next to
the oist the oist
you're already in the competition there
you're on the o list by proxy by proxy
wait what at Anson's chocolate it's the
oist and then
you podcast well no
association clearly no full Association
but like whatever it's not funny I
guarantee you anyone who's in the
category with opra it's not funny it's
not it can't be and no disrespect comp
in that vertical you know we love her
yeah no we we love Oprah just not for
the opra you know she did give us Dr Oz
also and Dr Phil also very important to
know it's not good it's her birthday so
andj shett right yeah we we wish her a
happy birthday okay okay it is it is
excuse me ab and I speak up I didn't
know you guys already wish her happy
birthday sorry Oprah if you're listening
happy birthday from me personally she I
thought personally she's
70 mhm I am a simp for Dr Phil f as
for real though these are pretty
big guests though oh this is just Jett
they they didn't have nothing to do with
this
what the man Sesame Street is
getting nominated not us like what what
are all these award shows even man I'll
tell you what the streamy is the only
one that actually like scammed their way
to somewhat relevance although I would
even question relevance of that these
new AG award shows award shows are just
falling out I think in
general you know somebody uh Gabe uh
member from 41 months shout out said uh
J shed's been advertising his toy
podcast on my local radio station
telling people he got Michelle Obama on
it's so
embarrassing I want to hear that ad so
true Gabe wait I want to hear that ad
yeah we should see if we
can find that somehow okay you got
Michelle Obama now make me laugh
dummy okay can can you interview
Michelle Obama and also be funny no I
didn't think so dumb
[Music]
eyes his eyes look subdued there
mhm they don't have their usual
Sheen all right let's get off this talk
about the same two guys enough occupying
all my brain it's not Ryan it's Jay
shett and that's all there is to talk
about this a little piece of
work
little Masterpiece of art created by one
of our
fans
um one second here as you guys know we
have a fondness for gay related sound
bites and uh somebody has made a not
great why it is great it just doesn't
sound great it is what it is we do all
right we do I'm gay I want to say this
for a long time I looked at myself in
the mirror
myself the
com
G that is so
good
like
G did did they add Reverb you know or is
it really that resonating I think it's
that powerful
dude like the planet's aligning yeah you
now I felt uh
gay so that's very good shout out to um
banded Coral shrimp Coral shrimp yeah
love
you top commment is I felt that in my
bone marrow that's what it is for Real
this deep
resonance y okay don't need to get
demonic with
it
um
oh your dad sent to yeah so when he was
in the states he was using my car and
it's the only he actually listened to
the radio while driving around my car or
your car my car okay I was just curious
if he was in my car or not cuz that'd be
interesting no no uh but yeah he he
heard a Shad and he recorded it and he
sent it to me back no way yeah okay it's
kind of low so you got to crank it known
for his indelible onscreen presence in
both tent pole and Art House films
Charlie demilio gained immense
popularity on Tik Tok her meteoric rise
to fame made her one of the most
followed and recognized individuals with
millions of followers listen to on
purpose with J shed on the iHeart Radio
App or wherever you get your podcast
when you switch to Boost
Mobile Jay that was Jay desperate for
attention that's corny
bro keep playing keep playing a23g in a
pretty
power your dad even hit us with the soy
so let me get the timeline right he
filmed this in LA and he just sent it to
you now no so he sent sent me to sent it
back then yeah he told me he pulled over
to record ended up being worth it yeah
good job Hawk yeah good job listen to
this idiot one more
time his indelible onscreen presence in
both tent pole and Art House films
Charlie Deo gain popular on Tik Tok What
is the Giant how are those things
connected he's talking about giant
tentpole films and then all of a sudden
he's talking about Charlie demilio this
guy's a loser idiot you don't listen to
that anymore do you
Sam I is Sam here I think she may oh
there she is you don't listen to that
anymore right Sam no I'm so sorry I was
chewing rice yeah it's okay it's
okay
okay I cannot close this
what is
happening okay there what is that I have
to godamn um I haven't listened to J
shete in a while thank God and you're
probably mentally in a much better place
well no I mean I still like it I just
haven't listened to it in a
while okay well if you liked it you
probably you know things I like I
participate in
so you know I'm just banking them all
going to going to listen to them all at
once
mhm uh POS podcaster says women should
be worried her man could kill her at any
moment
Vibes this is this the red pilled for
women podcast no this is a new
one murder
porn what a psycho that dude is
all right so here's an interesting take
uh
ladies guy shouldn't be dating a woman
that's more than two-thirds of his body
weight the woman should feel smaller so
wait now we're weighing them and doing a
ratios of body weight well you'll see
why feel he could kill her but he's not
going to if I'm holding a girl and
subconsciously she knows that if I
wanted to I could pick her up and throw
into the wall but I'm not what she's
like okay trust him he's in control of
himself bro you need to go to jail he's
Dennis from implication he's literally
bitching that dude you who filmed this
and put it online who is this guy okay
now I need to find out more about him
it's a really small podcast um they have
like 30k on Tik Tok I need more Clips
please when sex happens when crimes
happen Jesus when
murders this bro really recorded that
and put it online guy shouldn't be
dating a woman that's more than 2/3 of
his body weight the woman should feel
smaller she needs to feel scared of
women his weight
right yo that girl could probably beat
my
ass I'm not
interested he could kill her but he's
not going to if I'm and then like girl
what are you doing there
run girl and subconsciously she knows
that if I wanted to I could pick her up
and throw into the wall but I'm not
she's like okay I trust him he's can
control of
him
[Music]
yeah oh my goodness yeah too far too
far I was saying without repeating funny
though yeah it's funny it was it was it
was really funny but too much I
was saying funny um that it's funny in
these people are getting way too
comfortable that incels need to go back
in the basement mhm right it was better
it was better before it was funer than
that we all felt bad for them we're like
oh we got to do something no send them
back basement
so this is too
much speaking of too much uh when I
missed you guys wishing Oprah happy
birthday the first time it's cuz I heard
Jimmy Lee was live
and I went to go look for a second and
immediately I turn into the stream and
he goes uh we love the black people
don't we folks we need the black people
and I just wait Jimmy's live right now
he was live on Instagram he just ended
that's all he had okay all right
exciting up to the we do love the black
folks I mean we do love them he's right
they're
terrific like everybody I'm sure that
statement was preface was a lot more
than Jimmy but yeah
certainly nothing racist was said by him
but being gay and being black is
different yeah I mean yes Jesse of
course I don't think all black people
are gay by any means that would be weird
lesbians lesbians yeah they're gay too I
technically Zach it's just incredible
how he says that lesbians by the way I
keep trying to get a hold of this guy
cuz I love him so much and he he's
ghosting us yeah he's not interested too
big time for us he's too big time he's
Jesse Lee Peterson it's not fair man I
want my I want my go with
him how did you become
gay I mean as far as question goes
that's
phenomenal it's like saying how did you
become black what an interviewer I think
that isn't that what I think that's what
the gentleman responds with oh he did
maybe you're right yeah yeah yeah C
speaking of psychotic uh Alpha takes
here's candy candy Owens
candy fortunately that is I think her
and Jesse would probably make good
friends I don't know but
um here she is talking about if she saw
a female pilot she'd be terrified to get
on the plane what the Carl you do
not have to hate yourself that much but
unfortunately that is the reality of
what happens when it comes to Dei and
what he is remarking on is through I
would be terrified if I got onto a plane
and I saw a woman flying the plane and I
know that we have the United CEO saying
that he just wants to fulfill a quota he
just wants there to be more women and
what on Earth I see okay wants to be
more black people and he's not concerned
at first with qualifications that is
something that should alarm all of us
guys honestly so they're just picking
people off the street to fly the planes
yeah exactly um
is that really a bad thing like if you
look at Pilots it probably is like
massively male
dominated um yeah definitely so I mean
ever G on a plane and had a woman not
that I can remember I don't feel like I
ever have I did yesterday oh well there
you go and I got here on time and safely
there you go safely yeah ah okay that's
an anomaly apparently
apparently what is it Dei that's the new
thing diversity equity and
inclusion yes I think you actually got
that
correct Equity not equality right oh
maybe it's Equity no that's what you
said and I think that's correct oh
Equity yeah that makes more sense divers
than
equality equity and
inclusion yeah
Dei you know what you know what I feel
about
Dei if you flip the I and the E it says
die what our society is going to do if
we follow this yep
has anyone pointed that
out I think I'm the first has anyone
even realized
that not until now this is huge please
quote and please credit me guys if you
ever see that die I have another
clip actually um Charlie Kirk talking
about the same thing basically oh God is
this becoming a thing with the female
Pilots this is the thing what are we
talking about people women can women can
fly airplanes
they're capable they have the same parts
required to fly them that we do right we
men
do I'm a black pilot I'm qualified and
Charlie Kirk is hold on he's saying
black Pilots now can't fly what year is
this so they're they're God they're
talking about like diversity hires in
not to defend them because they are
wrong but their their their whole new
wave is that you know these kind of
programs to try and encourage diversity
and hiring is causing them to hire
underqualified candidates in order to
fill quotas do they have any evidence of
that I wonder I mean um are they really
doing Dei with Pilots uh definitely not
and the thing with the I feel like the
pilot one in particular is probably the
worst example that you could pick
because to be the like qualif the
regulatory barriers to becoming a
commercial airline pilot true are so
incredibly high that like regardless
anybody that's able to pass that is
definitely going to be competent you
know what I mean that's true they make a
better point with avation is one of the
tightly most tightly regulated things in
the whole country and so it's it's a
very it's a bad point to begin with but
trying to make that point with
commercial pilots just seems especially
misguided uh 70% of Pilots are male I'm
seeing
here 70% that's a pretty significant
that's high but yeah it's not yeah
there's probably even
more uh fields that are even less
diverse than that somebody saided if
most Pilots are men haven't all major
plane crashes been by men that is a
fantastic Point Checkmate Checkmate
oh my
God also Amelia aart right yeah she's
not a super great face fale Aviation we
don't yeah that doesn't help she doesn't
represent super we don't talk about
about Amelia just chilling she didn't
crash yeah know she did it she's fine
she did she's
Brave and she's dead well you know what
she's Brave it's true to bring her up is
the woman who's probably most famous for
crashing and disappearing well someone
had to do it first yeah that's true not
a good not a frankly not a great start
for women pilots hel Keller was a great
pilot hel K yeah we talked about that
before I don't buy it I think she what
else she do skydiving she what else she
do she she's Olympian she did a lot she
see the track she's doing part of she's
doing like a relay race and Olympic
relay race yeah did yeah right maybe a
potato sack
run God all right my next question for
them would be would you prefer prefer a
woman pilot or an Arab pilot I want to
see the I'm not answering that not you
them I'm I'm
staining well apparently I love all
Pilots I think they're making it clearer
if it's anything but a white male they
must be unqualified and the only reason
that they're there I well let me see
what these Knuckleheads have to say
about black Pilots yeah story in the Dei
story hits so hard because we've all
been in the back of a plane when the
turbulence hits or when you're flying
through a storm and you're like I'm so
glad I saw the guy with the right stuff
and the square jaw get into the cockpit
before we took off and I feel better now
think I mean like you want to go thought
crime like I'm sorry if I see a black
pilot I'm going to be like boy I hope
he's qualified okay um God first of all
you want to go thought crime you just
said that right out loud yeah not
no longer a thought that's not thought
yeah bro you definitely should have kept
that One in the Chamber that's crazy
that is a crazy ass thing I mean like
you want to go thought crime like I'm
sorry if I see a you want to go thought
thought crime I think sheep are
hot what that's a thought crime that's
something we can discuss yeah yeah can
we unpack that real quick what did you
just say I I'm just I'm doing a thought
crime for Cameron I'm giving him other
ideas cuz I've never heard that you want
to do a thought
crime
okay um I flush baby wipes oh oh that's
a real crime dude that's not a thought
crime go ahead I mean like you want to
go thought crime like I'm sorry if I see
a black pilot I'm going to be like boy I
hope he's qualified dude we got to cut
that I can't believe that that's why
we got to cut
that the you would have done that you
would have you would have done that all
the white men in the room way
the widest crustiest
the Council of
racist bags has
spoken Jesus Christ if I saw Charlie
Kirk as my P pilot then I'd be afraid
I'd be like is that guy even human right
I am repulsed by all four yeah they're
gross it's pretty bad it's pretty
bad qualified well that's the you would
have done that you wouldn't have you
would have done that before that's not
an immediate you would who I am that's
not what I believe it is the reality the
left has
created wait it's a left fault you're
racist it's the left's fault that I get
scared when I see a black man it's
actually the left fa at least he's like
he's like I have racist thoughts but I
don't want to have racist thoughts right
and before and before they were just
thoughts now I have to talk about it on
a podcast I mean with my boys we got to
work this out boys why do I keep having
racist
thoughts it is kind of interesting
though he goes that's not who I am it's
kind of interesting actually well that's
the you would have done that you
wouldn't have you wouldn't have done
that before that's not an immediate you
not who I am that's not what I believe
it is the reality the left has created
the reality the left has created all
right the cope is crazy that is
crazy
also I mean Charlie let's be real these
planes they practically fly themselves
these days absolutely fine although some
of them ain't that new yeah tell you
that much I could probably land a plane
you think so yeah
easy I don't think I could me neither oh
we have I play Ed a plane before me too
really I flew a plane once guys we have
um we have black Pilots uh responding oh
he we'll come back to that he just
posted the clip mhm Alex Cole he says
he's a black pilot I'm a black pilot and
Charlie Kirk is racist yeah couldn't
have said it better well I hope you know
what you're
doing don't let us down Alex we're
rooting for you
buddy
um so anyway that's that we've
got okay this Jennifer Lopez trailer got
claimed so whatever this so sad because
it's very funny it's one of my favorite
things of the
Year all right so we got did you watch
it yeah no it was wild yeah it was like
just
wild I can't wait to be honest I'll be
watching yeah all right um I got a pee
there's a few more things I want to get
to here and then we'll do the Abba and
preach response but we got to do the
actually the AL mcro update as
well um right that's the title and if we
have time we'll do redo doing the period
simulator now that I'm lost weight
somebody pointed out on the subreddit oh
yes that I had made an excuse that
because I have so much fat in my stomach
it made it um more painful yeah so we'll
see I'm not excited to try it I my
feeling is that it's probably going to
feel the same and I don't want to do
that right but I I'll be honest with you
guys
exposed all right I'll be right back
okay we'll be right here not taking
pause to pee Dan tell your story please
it isn't much of a story I just I went
to a flight school Thing Once and uh and
flew a plain I think I I feel like I've
talked about it on the show at some
point cuz I remember talking about the
fact that um they really did not give me
much training that's
crazy like I went and I did like the
simulator thing and they kind of quizz
me on uh on you know termin ology and
stuff probably did the training for like
an hour and a half 2 hours and then we
went up in a two- seat plane with me and
the instructor and yeah granted the
instructor's there and he can take over
at any point but that still felt even to
me I was like a bit quick really we're
already going out to the runway yeah
yeah yeah my family gifted me one of but
it was fine it those experiences I got
no training they was like yeah jump in
the plane there's for no training yeah
yeah just chilling when that he started
the plane flew up and I just got full of
control I flew over my house and
like that super cool yeah I mean it was
fun it was a really cool experience but
um yeah they let me do everything in
fact he was going to let me land and I
did everything right up to the end and I
chickened out like as we were
approaching the runway I was like you
should take over for this last uh 30
second uh period it just felt like maybe
not on the first go maybe not do this
part on the first you could landed
though you like you could I probably
could have but just I was getting
nervous as we were like coming in I was
just like keep your hand keep your hand
on it you know ready to take over I
could land a plane with less seats than
20 I could land it alone easy dude okay
yeah EAS all right you say so you
say so a plane right now prove it I
won't be I won't be hopping on that
plane with you but you can go ahead
I'll join you let's go dude you put your
life In Love hands like that sure based
on his words he's a wi kid come on dude
course he's a whiz kid speaking ofia
aart funny enough I Googled her name
like there's a sonar team that thinks
they might have found her playing yeah
she's fine she's she she was chilling
she's
fine wait did did uh this just happened
yeah literally just like just happened
where is it like in the ocean yeah yeah
um here go to B her out like Captain
America dude yo we take it back what we
said earlier about her she is a good
representation uh 16 person De Queen
yeah deep sea vision is what it's called
she didn't die she's
Dei Charlie Kirk looks like a blowup
doll from airplane oh true oh wow except
he doesn't get head right right he's got
no no um no
cash Charlie's real anger lies in that
his eyes are too close together to fly a
plane that's true and we shouldn't make
fun of that that's a disability it's not
cool so a it was never confirmed that
she crashed it's just assume that she
crashed there's theories that she might
have stranded off the coast somewhere in
the Pacific she swam back dude she swam
dude Amelia swam I like AB that she's
just fine yeah like she's just still
kicking yeah I think a bunch of like
misogynist just made up that she crashed
right trying to keep a girl down
yeah um please explain the Nicki Minaj
Megan the stallion rap beef nope nope
not getting into that I don't want the
smoke uh my boyfriend is a pilot well
cool congratulations that's it that's
pretty are they
black what well they said my boy my
boyfriend's a pilot I mean that's not
enough information right right yeah it
is a bit odd but I still appreciate it
thank you Vivian that's cool actually
congrats like you bagged a pilot that's
that's good Ethan I have to say this is
the third time since I've played the
holding music that you come back
perfectly at the end interesting like
right when it's the rhythm of the show
how long is it there uh it's 4 minutes
and 6 seconds how long he needs to he
takes me there you
go um let's see there's a couple of good
donos here I'll thank real fast
um Eddie says I'm preparing an analysis
of triller's S1 and as a former
investment banker will have my detailed
notes ready by Thursday morning to share
how do I get so what is what does that
mean S1 that's their uh SEC filing to um
go public oo so Eddie says how do I get
it in your hand I would love to email it
to me for sure Eddie I love to see that
yeah I I I looked over it a little bit
too um specifically somebody had pointed
out that there's an entire section in
there about Ryan's compensation package
so we like because it's all public so we
know what his deal with triller was in
in great detail oh man that's
interesting but I'm sure like it's most
of it's over my head but if Eddie here
is a investment banker then he could
probably provide us a lot more info if
this IPO goes well and Ryan gets a
payout I I don't understand anything
about this world I really don't think it
will I don't know there's zero I mean in
my mind there's 0% chance this company
is hemorrhage hemorrhaging millions of
dollars yeah it's barely
online they are in debt they have no
money in the bank literally they
don't H and they're going public I mean
what the is
happening all right growing up uh in
Scientology Dylan said this Dylan
Chatterton gram Scientology said he
would love to come on the Pod what does
that mean why you talking in third
person I feel like it's maybe a YouTube
channel called growing up in Scientology
oh he's the largest ex Scientology
Channel and he grew up in the sea org
also works with streets La he asked us
to reach out so I'm passing along the
message oh that could be interesting
conille grew up in the sea org that's
like their cruise ship oh wow those are
like the hardcore that
pledged their soul for a trillion years
huh he has 250k Subs on
YouTube cool that' be we be interested
in talking to them that could be yeah I
think so um they'll learn a little bit
more about them yeah uh Vivian says is
Jimmy on tiger belly or bad friends I
think it's tiger belly tiger belly yeah
yeah Ethan's hair looking good matches
the fit thank you Alex Franco thank you
my new work uh
my new work givers gives me a free
subscription to the Comm app and J shed
is all over it I won't betray the
family I'm so s how are people not over
this guy like he's so oversaturated now
Jay yeah it's getting to be too much
we're just promoting him by talking
about him all the time how many new
listeners do you think he got from our
audience probably quite a few yeah cuz
people because like they see how
beautiful his eyes are and they're like
maybe this guy has MH he's got something
I listen to his podcast just the audio
and I go I can hear that this guy has
beautiful eyes right he was he has a
nice voice too like he has a soothing
voice MH he was on the Today's Show four
days ago talking about congratulations
what today today he's not don't people
promote when they could do that stuff
he's probably promoting um his um his or
his uh Consulting uh uh coaching thing
his beautiful eyes Is that real yeah
today yeah that thing that you sent
that's totally real no it's not yes it
is are you with me no I'm not
with you at all no that's 100%
real I'm really why you saying it like
you're choking I think it's funny that
you're so skeptical that it's real why
is that be so scammy like transparent
it's a self-help you know Tony Robbins
does the same thing K and Cobb says when
I get my my psychology assessment and
was diagnosed with major
depressive uh the psychologist
recommended me one of Jay shed's podcast
episodes no way as the next step in my
report maybe that's a good suggestion I
don't know I haven't listened don't
listen to your doctor you know what I
mean yeah I'm just making fun of his
eyes and and his oversaturation he might
be a genius I don't know and I'll never
know because I'm not listening to his
he's a genius Communicator
that's for
sure all right I gotta get off Jay shett
I could talk about him all day so next
up we've got Austin MC Brom Aban
preach McBroom MC Brom MC Brom MC Brom
yeah we gotta do mcom I'm feeling it too
so this is turned into quite a debate
online and here in the office we've been
following Austin's sad
pathetic
um fall into single loneliness that's
what we do he's been posting tons of
snaps MH like here's one for
example that are posted another wild one
today you see the one I said pull it
up this is one from yesterday I
can't sleep yeah TR you can start by
turning the light
off it's bright as in there yeah
what the he got like a spotlight in
his eyes that's the brightest light I
ever
[Music]
seen look like he was crying but like
he's sitting there holding his blanket
like he's trying trying to look pathetic
yeah so there's something going on
there's another one Dan show me that one
okay it's just that it's like one second
long he just posted
this wow there's just no
shock but um one more time
so awesome dude yeah I've done
that Rush
[Music]
so but this is when it the Intrigue
really stepped up he put this video out
he said he was talking originally about
getting a house near his
EX's in this video he explains he
couldn't get that house and so he got an
RV and where is the RV right outside her
house check this video out and then tell
and then we got to discuss living
situation unfortunately I was was unable
to move into the home that I really
really wanted and you guys know how much
that meant to me because I get to be as
close as I can be to my kids but I did
figure out another solution that is just
temporary
but it's as best as I can do for now and
I'm happy with it and as long as they're
happy and I'm happy that's all that
matters so this is what I did I was able
to get this new motor this what this is
what I think's happening he he's
obligated to Snapchat to post a ton of
content it's his only source of income
at this point so he's forced to share
all this humiliating because like
that he can't avoid it can't not post it
he has to post 200 times a day or
whatever yeah anyway sorry I I
interrupted at the best part you're
happy and I'm happy that's all that
matters so this is what I did I was able
to get this new motor home and so I'll
be living here
temporary and they're right here so I
still get to be super close to my kids
wait why are you showing their house
yeah all of it wait what the bro
why are you showing the front of your
family's house and then your motor home
too people can they
shouldn't yeah definitely not but yeah
no it's just like yep here's the house
they uh they've always been like that
though like think about their uh they
weren't careful at all in their like Ace
family Vlogs or whatever with their
house very obvious where their house was
I feel felt like this was part of why I
got a little bit suspicious like why
would he just show the front of the
house I figured he was just using like
an RV a friend's RV to like pretend like
it was his to just create content
and well we we can proa we can figure
out if that's the house or not just go
watch some of their recent videos yeah I
don't think they care I mean they think
the jet skis they were making it rain on
the whole the whole city below them
exactly that's what I mean never been
careful about it that house had a
defensible high ground true true true
these are just on the
neighborhood you know it could still be
in a gated community I suppose okay
maybe yeah that that that would make it
less crazy yeah it would CH says the
neighbors are going to get his RV toad
I'm s you can't park a fat RV on
the street like that can you you
absolutely can you can I mean have you
driven around La
lately dude there was one RV there RVs
all over the place we had limited
parking our old department and there was
one RV that came every week and
took up like three spots yeah just cuz
it's free parking it was so annoying
what I didn't I didn't know you could do
that I I think by the letter of the law
you can't but they don't enforce it at
all that's eviden by there being RVs all
over the place I've never lived in the
city where parking's an issue not in La
other cities right Israel New York
right but yeah I hate that there's
nothing worse dude than go going home to
your neighborhood to your house and
there's no
spots
yeah done that a lot but don't you guys
have like now I have a parking spot yeah
don't you guys should have your own
parking spot yeah just I don't know I
lived in many apartments where I had to
park on the street not anymore not
anymore I got a parking spot dude I'm
that's made it
bro you moving up that's that's upward
Mobility M
right hell yeah you know right across
the street from me so just a little
update for you guys big Z with me he's
driving oh I haven't seen this move into
my place the last few days wait hold on
there's one where he gives a tour yeah
that's it's the next link okay good and
um I got something to share with you
guys you know regarding my living
situation it's been a little complicated
and there was like a minor minor setback
and I know in that end it'll be a a big
comeback you know so it's a little just
a little minor setback but you know
everything is working out and U getting
ready to show it to you guys I'm
excited um you know it's a big change
for me it's a big change for us but
um can we share oh God I got some some
breaking news that makes it look even
more sus uh he supposedly got a ticket
for this uh RV and some sort of
neighborhood watch flyer I sent the
video go okay wait why does that make it
more SS it just look at it all right
here's a recent Tik Tok you posted about
it Austin McBroom got a ticket Faking It
For The Views I just don't never know I
woke up this morning um and had a good
ass night even though it was a little
cold woke up this morning to a damn
ticket okay hold on what the let's
read
that oh come on come on man come on man
all right I gotta go back and then pause
it on it good night I can't move it
frame by
frame
tiet too blurry yeah there's I can't
really if you go to the very start
that's probably the best freeze of it
when the AI voice is
talking oh yeah right there neighborhood
watch violation this
vehicle yeah what that looks so fake I
guess if it's like a homeowner
association doing it it might look like
that I could see some uh yeah the
neighbors putting that and he didn't
show the ticket which would be I mean
you wouldn't show the ticket cuz it's
got private info on it not that he cares
and his license and
stuff let me watch Austin McBroom got a
ticket Faking It For The Views I so M
right now I woke up this morning um and
had a good ass night even though it's a
little cold what is he wearing on his
head it's a good question I think a
bonnet to keep his hair it's like a
cornrow
thing no uh no it just keeps your hair
from like messing on the pillowcase I
don't know I've seen sometimes when
people do cornrows they like but he has
like Curly
yeah I don't know what's going on under
the hood there under the Bonnet yeah it
does look like a
bonnet
hold this morning for damn ticket ticket
where
at 7:13 they left this ticket on
my Windfield saying that neighborhood
was alert this area so look closely
because in the tour which is the main
video I want to show you guys he's
wearing the same shirt with a stain on
it here
right so he's wearing the same dirty
tank top for several
days I feel like the stain is like oh
how how should I look even worse I can
stay in my shirt I mean can he really be
that pathetic I mean I mean all right
let's keep I want to believe I want to
believe that he's full like uh uh what
was uh mil House's Dad Kirk he's going
full Kirk
here
um I'll tell you right now I think it's
all real but we'll get into that all
right we'll get into that okay I used to
live here you are not a resident of this
neighborhood you may not leave your Park
vehicle on the street for more than 72
hours
that's know but violation What officer
did this like people he's just a dumbass
it was obviously just like the HOA or
neighbors or something doesn't look like
he got a ticket at all he's just talking
about this be most of my
kids dealing with this now and
thank God that my neighbor let me park
let me park in their property and I'm
like not too far from the house I can
still see like through the tree a little
bit I can come on this can't be
real he's he could see through the
tree it's
unbelievable C through the tree so that
makes um but now I'm done with this and
I don't know if I should try to park it
back and see if going come back give me
another ticket or what I should do now
it's not a
ticket guys it's one thing after another
crazy before I got this damn ticket
I was supposed to do get ready with me
in my new house for you guys but I'm be
honest like not the mve for it oh okay
this is before the RV tour mm so it
could be the same day actually it might
be the same day it's not feeling um
getting ready to start I'll probably
just head to church and hopefully things
get better for there um maybe Circle
back around to get ready with me I know
you guys were requesting for me to do
like a bunch of v in my new house so may
why it so fast did I do that no uh maybe
it was recorded that way suck know like
like I'm doing good like I'm doing good
and I'm happy looks like but just sucks
when like this type happens people
try like stop you from like leveling up
you know um so I don't know I'm figuring
it out um hope you guys are doing good
thanks for always checking in on me
appreciate the love and support as
always you know there's like get Ready's
with me this is get be sad with
me so I'm about to finish getting ready
and then I'll just take you guys with me
and we'll figure out what the rest of
the day has offer are you freaking
kidding me bro this dude's propping him
on right now his sprinklers turned on
and it's wet in my whole new house I
just got this
washed BR you know when one thing after
another just keeps happening to you I
feel like that right now he can't be for
real he can't be but watch the the tour
is where it really uh shines okay okay
here's the
tour and this one
is it got I'll tell you what I started
questioning the whole thing after I saw
this because it's like it's like a
sketch I mean the way that
it's it's the most pathetic divorced dad
of all
time all right here it is the big tour
so he's in the same tank top but he's
not wearing the
Bonnet watch your
[Music]
step wait who's filming him this is
where I'm going be one of his homies
probably the dude who's in the car with
him yeah he has a friend be us Catherine
it's got it yeah I I know I think about
all this so watch the okay D y'all fire
so check it out this my living room
right here it's my living room I just
got this bro bought you know this dude
has a pillow decorative pillow that says
home with the tag still on it on his
Lazy Boy that's that has to be a
prop
y
if this turns out to all be real I mean
holy
a few accessories to make it feel
like home yeah that's put me right
at that is is a poem in itself if I'm
being honest the back of the pillow is
just mobile the new home pillow in the
new mobile here's my dining room table
basically fits all my kids so it's
perfect uh just got this TV in as you
can see like this is brand new like tape
is on here and then why I don't know why
he's trying to prove that he got a new
TV too that it's like he's like yo this
is brand new look
the like I mean TVs aren't even that
expensive you could get a TV like that
for like a hundred bucks
yeah commercial like brand new guys like
everything's brand new what are you up
okay over here's my kitchen so what's
that
about it's tank up being covered in fil
what is those shoes what are those Zach
you got any intel on these crazy ass
sneakers I need a better look at those
are slippers they sell them at the mall
they look like they like Air Maxes yeah
well they're supposed to be the uh oh
yeah weather Sean weather I forget his
name oh the Sean the Air Max yeah yeah
yeah but they're actually just slippers
they're like $20 at the mall got it but
the real shoes go for like a grand yeah
yeah and the grease stain on the on the
on the tank top is bananas
he doing tour he didn't put on a clean
shirt
right it's kind of a big kitchen for you
know motor home got the stove here got
the
microwave uh again like everything is
brand new um the sink is right here
little hidden sink you know what I'm
saying uh you come over here I got the
fridge the tape still on the fridge
freezer tape still on the fridge yeah
why is he why is he obsessed with like
this isn't this is all new he's insecure
about being
broke right but why would even if that's
true why would you display your
insecurities so outwardly well I think
he's trying to say this is temporary
because on his stories today he's doing
a bunch of Tours open houses yeah open
houses like $20 million houses okay but
hold on you don't buy this RV probably
cost like a million bucks or or or or
close to it so you don't just buy an RV
like this for like a couple
weeks get an apartment why the
would you spending like a million bucks
on an
RV no
credit there's no shot this dude can
afford a $20 million house was he really
looking at those yeah
yep if he buys one of those again I'm be
I'll be mystified I mean that's Ryan
kavanau levels of feeling upwards well
this is like a popular thing on Tik Tok
of people uh doing tours of homes they
can't afford and I feel like that's just
what he's doing also to fill that
content Gap that you're talking about on
Snapchat
right yeah there's no way that he can
afford the houses that he was touring
there's no way he's planning on being in
this RV for a long time that's the only
explanation keep walking over here even
got long shower it's crazy it's crazy
like literally stand up
shower want to come this way I'll show
you the the room first this is the I
mean it's a nice
RV yeah it's great it's a very nice RV
not going to talk on the RV but
parking it across from your wife ex-wife
and then spying on her through the bush
is pretty
weird Master it's the master sorry I got
just stuff everywhere right now somebody
said my parents have an RV that size and
it's like like 100k is it really that
cheap yeah I would say more yeah around
150 yeah Ultra Luxury the I'm
buying an RV my dad funny enough after
my dad got a divorce he got a RV not to
live in it but he bought an RV similar
to this actually probably a little nicer
I think it was around
170 nicer than this I'm buying one to
live in that go park house house
yeah whoa this one's crazy wait hold the
phone how do that that all in
RV extend extend yeah the sides pop out
yeah oh it's extended got it got
it
ah 1.3
million it says this one oh you know all
be yours for 1.3 million yeah actually
my dad's doesn't it's not a it's just
the trailer part it doesn't drive I
forgot about that so oh that's kind of
of a big
difference I mean looks wise it looks
exactly the same from
inside I think it's it's pricey it's on
RV at the it's just a house mhm right
the closet got RV without an
engine so he's never used the bed
clearly it's covered in
plastic he doesn't cover his bed with
plastic does he no that's crazy
crazy
I'll show you the room first this is the
the
master the master and I got my own
master closet but look nobody says
master closet in an RV it's like he's
trying to be more
pathetic master
closet I mean it's nice for an
rvu but get everything in
here so yeah this is my master TV every
room got a TV in it so um this bed is
probably one of the most comfortable
beds that could even be in a motor home
like I had to customize basically like
this room for the for the mattress to
Kit
cozy know
nice pass you real quick excuse me oh um
here's the master bathroom right here
Master super spacious uh we got the
heated the heated toilet is there two
bathrooms on this no yeah master
sink is nonm bathroom that there's one
bathroom yeah there's one bathroom
custom for the water to stay cold got
the mirror the mirror with what does
that the drawer like that crazy the sink
is made for the water to stay
cold huh see he's saying that don't
make sense but he goes he goes look I've
got a
mirror yeah in the bathroom for the
water to stay cold the water to stay
cold
what are you doing in that sink brother
also wouldn't you want warm water isn't
that more desirable right absolutely
yeah got the mirror the mirror with the
the drawer like that
crazy then I got extra window and peep
out check make sure the family's good no
shot he said
that he
meing imagine your your dad who just got
divorce from your mom is parked in an RV
across the street and you can see him
watching you guys through a tiny window
he's not serious he can't be so here's
the thing can we get into this the fake
real not yet not yet okay I mean yeah
why not we'll finish the the video but
yeah we can we can get into
it I mean I guess it's just
it if he is
meming and this is like satire he's
somehow doing this performance like
that's what it would have to be right
he's decided I'm going to do this
elaborate thing where I try and make
myself as pathetic as possible as like
the most divorced dad of all time if
that's what he's
doing it's
like comedy genius level and then the
dedication they've never done anything
like this never done anything like that
and we know that he is extremely
egotistical does somebody like that not
funny make himself the subject of like
this long form prank joke that's what
that was my hard to he he that's my
hangup he does he gains Nothing by
pretending to be uh lonely and pathetic
there's no part of his audience cuz it's
like he has he has his genuine fans who
like him for the stupid ass like Ace
family dad Persona that he puts on or
whatever they like that he's not and
then there's people like us that are
haters that react to his content and
we're just going to find it funny and
pathetic that he's doing this so who is
that for I think creating this narrative
on Snapchat is Gonna Keep people engaged
people are going to be curious people
going See's happening I'm curious yeah
for sure people are watching right
everyone's super the clips I'm posting
about it it's getting a lot of views I
think it's I think he's getting a lot of
juice from Snapchat and Katherine's also
juicing Snapchat yeah I think they both
have some kind of a weird deal where
like let's do this let's monetize our
divor might have broken up for real but
we're going to doubting the divorce is
the the divorce is real the divorce is
real a little bit no it's got to be real
I mean they are scammers that would be
really crazy me I read some
cuckoo conspiracies about they are doing
a fake divorce so they can do bankruptcy
or some and Katherine can keep the
money I don't know some weird but I
feel like that's not how bankruptcy
works like there's just no way that you
can get out of it like
that I mean if they're desperate and
needed a plan Z I could see them faking
that I don't I'm not saying they are but
I'm not completely against what love is
saying either if they're faking it
making this whole narrative they're
juicing on Snapchat and then they get
back together somebody
said RV doesn't even look lived in no
food no product no bathroom so either he
just bought it
or he could be borrowing it he could be
renting it I think renting is most
likely but then so far I haven't seen
any evidence of actual use which I'm
curious if that's going to happen or not
or they just bought it and they're
trying to make like make it into a
business
expense you know what I mean recording
in it I see a lot of people saying it's
so obvious that he's trolling I I just
don't agree that it's obvious I don't I
think it's in a weird
ambiguous because we know Austin you
know we know Austin's content we know
his Persona and that would just be such
a 180 on he's not a comedian right he's
never done anything funny that I've
seen yeah no not at all um like family
content plus like him hyping himself up
pums and to add on to what love said
like just posting it on Snapchat is
suspicious like they made Their audience
on YouTube why would they like post
updates on YouTube n it's the same thing
as David Dober there it's probably an
exclusivity too if they're getting paid
could be
right because dude nobody's paying out
for this type of content like Snapchat
apparently MH but like they're known to
take breaks right both of them they take
these massive breaks disappear from the
internet for ages why wouldn't they take
a massive break when they're divorcing
it seems just so weird to because they
have he has these contracts he needs to
make money yeah but he's under
obligation we're back and now we're
going to start posing content and we're
going to have a divorce it just seems so
weird I think they they planned all this
honestly I there's no way it just it
doesn't fit in with the profile of who
they are I just don't see it I think
they're D bad and they need
juice and they're like let's try this
we got this SnapChat deal how do we
drive money to or how do we drive people
to Snapchat boom I don't think he would
that's true they're gen like that is
genius but I don't think that they at
but I just don't I don't know if they if
they have it in him I don't think he has
it in him to be this openly pathetic
well he is being pathetic right and if
he gets to in a couple months say you
know all of you we got you I'm not
actually do I'm not actually this
pathetic I was trolling then he gets
absolved of that that will never that
won't
happen this is what I think's happening
he's posting these he's trying to make
people feel bad for him and especially
Catherine to feel bad for him because
he probably she probably left him which
is all but but uh you know proven I
think from the messages and he he's
trying to make everyone feel bad for him
and people are siding with
Katherine
and I think that's all he can do is just
play for sympathy but he's taking it too
far I put money on it that he never is
like yo we're still together you
guys I don't think he's going to do it
that way I think it's going to be what
he thinks is like a Redemption Arc of
like I got my family back we love each
other I you know I found God I I changed
my ways this this that no shot no
shot she posted they are conniving so I
don't know she posted a a story of
someone changing her locks it seemingly
on Snapchat which is funny which also
changing his locks yeah some no on the
house here see if you can open that it's
like someone Chang I feel like that's
also Mimi somebody said okay let's see
when was this posted uh 23 hours
ago probably want to mute that oh yeah
but yeah it's just some dude that was it
yeah if you want to go back click on the
left Arrow wait it went to the next one
left yeah click that
Arrow so it's just like someone changing
the lock or seemingly I don't know I
just don't think that they're con them
baby I don't think they're on that level
I just don't
I think they're D
bad I mean imagine you're Austin you're
look at this beautiful family and this
beautiful home and he can't be in there
I think he's in there well yeah I think
he's he's actually in there okay I know
you do but think of it if he's actually
not yeah that's going to he's the guy is
down bad bad bad
yeah I don't know could we agree that
like that would be a potential plan Z
though like I I like if you had no other
option they've probably thought about
that for years like if we're lose our
relevancy we could fake a divorce oh Ela
just donated right now she said I think
it's a bit but I don't get what's the
angle joke that's what I'm saying it
doesn't benefit him he just looks
pathetic and he's he's too
egotistical I think Snapchat pays crazy
money like unbelievable amount of money
yeah and he's down to debase himself for
that kind of money we know he don't
really give a
about I don't know I I'd like I'd be
curious to
see the viewership uh over you know
charted over time to see if it's gone up
yeah oh it's definitely gone up after
the divorce right well I don't know it
probably did initially I don't know if
it stayed up you know cuz like there you
can only watch so much of this pathetic
kind of content It's just sad and it's
depressing like it's it's got novelty at
first but I don't think anybody's going
to keep watching this it's
sad I yeah well that's why I think he's
trying to build up like a Redemption
he's like mentioning church here and
there and like oh man this is so bad so
how could it get any worse and then he's
going to be like oh I went to church
started working out got healthy maybe I
don't know I did see that video CU they
are going to church together yeah with
his family he lives across the street
you know
all right here here let's continue
the
tour oh no this video is no longer
available what you talking
about this video is still
available go a
some of the comments he makes
coming up are so unbelievable though it
does make me wonder um here's the master
bathroom right here super spacious um
custom for the water to stay cold got
the mirror the mirror with the the
drawer like that crazy um then they got
an extra window and peep out check make
sure the family's good dude got the tow
he's not that funny like I don't think
he could think to say that and it's just
there's a presence of mind that I I just
I don't know I haven't seen it in them
maybe maybe I'm missing
something then this motor home so big
that it has like extra storage just
everywhere you know see more tiles and
mad storage
um keep coming down
here and like these are like the
most like expensive seats that you can
have in a motor home um they're the ones
that reclined all the way into a bed so
like you can lay right here and
like you remember what they said how to
do um I think the oh right
here yeah I
think
um it you guys get the point like it
comes all way out we can that be real
they can't be real that can't be real
another thing is legality if he's being
sued for something if they're divorced I
don't I don't know if that would be
considered she's not going to get out of
it for that they're both
liable there's no way there no way I
think they're just down bad for money
I'm not I don't think they're
necessarily getting sued or anything
well going bankrupt yeah I don't I think
they're just one money more money it
can't be that much more though to for
all this it can't be that much more it
can't
be I don't know it made David doic the
biggest like juicer creater basically
online to go only Snapchat that's C well
he was banished kind of yeah but he's
still getting views I feel like on Tik
Tok and yeah on Tik Tok not on
YouTube though I don't think people
watch him on YouTube that much maybe I'm
wrong well he hasn't
posted forever all right let's watch
this whole seat of fiasco
again you remember what they
said I think the oh right
here yeah I
think why would there be a button in the
cup holder that doesn't even make
sense it's definitely I know where it is
it's probably like under the cushion
right here there be in the cup holder no
shot you guys get the point like it
comes all the way out it clins all the
way to a bed so like there's one bed two
beds and then that big probably fit like
probably like five people in it so you
can fit like a whole like my whole
family here literally so that made me
like dude you you talking about your
kids sleeping on this as a dub that
your whole family can sleep there like
these two that's
horrible that's not good at
all
um you guys get the point out CLS all
the way to a bed so like there's one bed
two beds and then that bed probably fit
like probably like five people in it so
you can fit like a whole like my whole
family here literally no shot bro really
nice really nice and then these chairs
if I unhook the latch you can spin these
around this way and it comes into like a
full living room like this living room
it's probably like the same size as a
lot of like home living rooms you know
so yeah y'all that's the
this this is something interesting he
does he slaps his hand and his fist
together continually through this shot
so
loud it makes me think that it's just
too great of a detail it has to be
real like watch com below um again I'm
super happy um this is just temporary
and I got to do what I got to do for you
know my kids as long as you know my kids
are happy and I'm happy that's really
all that matters and you know I get to
be right next to them so again thank you
all for tuning in supporting us Place uh
you guys will see more videos me and RV
I'm going to have you know my family and
friends come over I'm going to surprise
them and
uh
wow dark colors going on here I don't
know man I mean like if if it's fake
they're doing what they're doing is like
genius mhm this and then the dedication
to playing this character it's like AV
on guard comedy he's he's Andy Kaufman
it it truly do you think that Austin MC
brom's an Avant guard
comedian I don't not a comedian but a
hustler an avangard Hustler a scammer if
there is some component of it that
they're able to do some finessing with
the divorce in regards to their failed
business maybe I could see them pulling
out all the s for that but again it's
just Austin just seems so like image
obsessed yes that it's hard for me to
believe that he would embarrass himself
like this even for the troll here's the
thing if they do end up getting back
together or something I'm going to
question big time well sure yeah but
like if they broke up for real there's
no shot they're getting back together
his pathetic ass out there in the RV
like she probably
probably looks at him with like disgust
like I can't believe I ever this
dude like there's just no way that she's
wanting that dude
back
me how did he even get a grease stain in
the middle of his sometimes you know you
just hanging out just hanging out under
your brand new RV doing some repairs all
right let's do a poll let's see what the
people think see what the people think I
guess just we got get this right let's
say
this is it
real is it real this is the beginning of
a bad poll real fake that's
it real or fake real includes if you're
thinking like it's 75% real and he's
Hamming it up I feel like that still
counts as real yeah I I don't think they
divorced even so that's the thing
is the divorce real or fake is that the
question is the divorce real or fake N I
don't think that's good because yeah
it's not good does Austin really live in
an RV is it um n just say is it real
real or fake real or fake that's too
vague that's a b the breakup real or
fake did they fake the divorce yes or no
because divor they could still be
together working on that divorce plot
together but is the breakup
real cuz if they could be like if some
people are think it's because they're
trying to separate the assets or
whatever but they're actually still
together do we need multiple
polls no okay let's if let's just try to
boil this down is the RV plot line fake
is the
RV plotline faked for
views faked for views yes yes no or no
this is the first time my weird you can
also add a third one that's like uh just
want to see the
results you know yeah that's good I feel
like this is the first time my weird
bizarre crazy Theory actually has
support I feel very Justified for once I
don't think it's completely out of the
question I just
think
again I just have a hard time believing
Austin McBroom is willing to to play
that role Avant guard comedy that you
would see at like 3:00 a.m. on a adult
swim well what if he doesn't have no
choice like he's going to lose
everything either way so this way he
builds the narrative the way he wants it
but then it's
real isn't it well no because they're
not actually splitting up like she's in
on what he's planning right now like he
has no choice he's going to be pathetic
either way but this way at least he has
some kind of control of like oh I lost
this but I got my wife back some some
positivity in the narrative I guess if
they get back together this shit's all
fake there's no shot she wants anything
to do with that
dude peeking through the bathroom window
like there's just no way I sent this
meme from the subreddit of him looking
through the window oh good we got memes
ready Austin MC Brom watching his kids
call another man dad from across the
street yeah pretty
much
man well the yes is uh the people that
believe it's fake are are winning quite
handly right now on the poll although
I'm getting incredible reports of a bad
poll here is the RV plot line faked for
views yes I can't believe y'all are
really so conspiratorially minded
there's just no
way we'll find out I mean if they don't
get back together then it was real you
know it for me this started as a small
suspicion way early but then every day
we cover it it's like that's weirder oh
that makes it even weirder so it's like
really just scaled up and I imagine if
this keeps going like this in my opinion
is going to be like black and white
after a couple weeks I agree we'll know
we'll know yeah okay and it's possible
but just because it's so pathetic it's
like a comic book it's like a sitcom
right divorc Dad sitcom yeah I
don't think he's like a big comic either
I don't think he is funny I just think
he's building this weird plot line not
necessarily for to be funny just to
engage people in in the story I don't
think he's trying to be funny what he
Pok that one yeah it leads into another
one of him in the shower he also posted
like two dogs humping each other for
like five different
stories Lauren says family my husband
has been ordering Swedish snoo and loves
it y'all should try it dude girl get out
of here who you work for big
tobacco it's disgusting bro what the
hell stop that why are you encouraging
us to try a drug I love that an
addictive
drug no don't do it y'all I I shot up
for the first time last night and it was
awesome it was fun I feel great
today yall should try it yeah it's
awful well all right we we will continue
to follow the story as it develops keep
an eye I'm C we'll all certainly be
watching
uh with Great Expectations mhm
mhm if if it comes out as fake I'll be
very
impressed just from a acting point of
view
yeah dedication point of view
like you know I feel like they they are
working less now than ever though like
they don't do YouTube I feel like this
is an easy thing and it kind of LED it I
don't think even they made it up it's
been rumors I think they just jumped on
the rumor they work less now than ever
they don't post YouTube videos don't do
Tik to do you think it's more plausible
that she actually just left him I think
that is plausible I don't think it's
impossible I mean look at him crazy like
you know and everybody people are
thirsting for her I see that she has you
know she has suitors I see him out there
they go she's a 10 you fumbled a 10 I
see people telling him sure so she's out
there but I just don't think they're
working hard right now they're they're
doing less work than ever would you
agree with that yeah I agree with that
based on what I can see yeah so I think
they're just chilling and having getting
money from Snapchat I definitely agree
with that God I wanted Snapchat money
I'll divorce heila for it whatever you
guys want I'll go live in an RV across
the street from my house right yo shorty
you looking good and like uh add my
girl on Snapchat wow he's
drunk gross all right so we have one
more what is this oh God is this okay
hold oh wait what okay I can show
these right I mean she's in
bikini yeah so Katherine is posting
mad thirst traps she looks bomb does she
usually post photos like this she said
I'll be here until further
notice
well does she usually before she does
now you know what I'm asking though like
is this a new thing or I would assume so
is this like for the course post it on
Instagram or oh on Snapchat of course on
Snapchat of course on Snapchat chat what
you look at what else what else there's
another
one
um oh my God you think Austin's looking
at these from the absolutely he
is um here's another one I guess this is
a video but I don't have the
video she's been posting similar stuff
on Instagram for a while for a long time
just scrolling down yeah this a couple
all right so it doesn't mean far for the
course yeah it doesn't mean definitely a
little bit more chill
dude this that isn't a video but that's
the last snap and so that's the preview
that's like the thumbnail of her
Snapchat whatever the last one is so
she's got it I mean she's still got it
Austin does not got it Austin does not
got it t top ain't nobody trying to
Austin
McBroom also the O soliciting lines up
with the patheticness that he's become
he's soliciting only fans models right
that is an important Instagram DM well I
have a counter if he's getting caught
doing something like that or some girl's
threatening him he cheated and she's
like I'm going to tell people this may
be part of the narrative as well come
I'm just saying there's that could work
as well he's not baiting people to
expose him that's crazy no not baiting
people to expose him but I mean like he
already got caught and being threatened
or whatever so it's part of the whole
we're getting divorced now because of
that because I was unfaithful or doing
why would they want that no they didn't
want it initially that I'm saying that
it got leaked and I'm or whatever it is
and that he's going along with that I
don't know time will tell I don't know
don't push don't push don't push we got
the dove don't push don't
push
um oh this is great it's the um Kingdom
Hearts how could you be so
heartless just those shoes he's got the
the shoes are for real he's got the had
to do it to him post
still that's such a funny picture of
him nice me this is wild well no
matter what's happening I'm captivated
yep
truly if it's real I feel bad I mean
this is down bad as down bad can
be he needs to sell the soil tank top as
merch that's funny that's actually funny
as nobody would buy it but it's
funny I think the Angels threw her down
and made sure she was not
coming I hope he doesn't say
that all right uh finally let's do the
ab and preach response but as your host
I have to tell you I need to pee again
bro moment you got 4 minutes and 8
seconds right Zach 408 yeah let me know
when we start he's walking he's already
walking okay
okay happy Monday everybody happy Monday
how was everyone's weekend how we doing
we ready for this week hell yeah baby
ready to tackle this thing nope no
what's wrong Zach I'm tired dude I'm
tired I'm kind of tired today too
new episode of True Detective
me up last night is it good is it
worth watching oh it's so good oh yeah
okay I'm going to have to do it going
have to jump back in we watched that
Sophia vagera show yesterday that was
really good Griselda oh my God I want to
see that yeah it was really good and she
it was crazy at one point I'm not going
to spoil anything but she did crack once
and it like the amount of she did
in that one night makes me think what
Ethan got up to that one day he tried
crack because she like up in
that one day so yeah yeah he hasn't
really gone into much detail about what
he did on crack we know that he did
crack right but do we know what he did
he said he didn't feel it which I don't
really believe who does Kraken that's
the guy I had sex with who smoke Kraken
with
me uh Clifford just donated five bucks
and said he lost his kid's house wife
and YouTube channel Revenue he's
definitely going insane for real I mean
that's a fair argument too he
does have good reason that actually
isn't even listing all of it because
didn't they also lose their
house
and his boxing career wasn't that like a
huge disaster too yeah he had that event
the first event didn't go well and the
second event he lost yeah so this is my
this is my this is my take take them at
their word we didn't believe in the
ace Fest it happened it was
wonderful right we don't believe in
divorce it happened it's tragic except
for I I hope Catherine has a Wonderful
Life yeah no you have a good point
though that we have um been burned yeah
we should just believe him at everything
done a lot to earn our trust yeah I mean
Ace Fest was still think about that yeah
it was a wonderful time it was a great
time 2 minutes I want to go back I never
you think there'll be a new ace best it
won't be the same you think so always
was that last year or two years ago two
years ago years wow that's crazy that's
crazy I want to go please bring it back
bring it back bring back the ace
Fest A3 Fest no noell I'm shut that idea
right
please WR down um you should uh you
should have Paul Banks from interpool on
the show he shouted you guys out a few
times he's a fan of the show you know
I've heard that I think it Zach you even
chatted with him at one point on
Instagram or something Paul's an amazing
guy he's really cool that's so cool yeah
from interpool yeah what what the
not the uh not the European get him not
that I'm on on the run from right right
right I'm
here
uh let's see has a minute and 3 seconds
oh he's got time he's making great time
got a minute dude this has been
happening to me recently have you guys
ever had this I get
um like maybe once a
week rapid fire like spam called
like literally back to back to back like
it finishes ringing and immediately
starts ringing again from scammers and
instead of just like occasionally
calling you they like bombard you
calling you over and over again if you
decline it it like instantly starts
ringing again I have not had that it's
happening right now my phone is like
going nuts I'm getting like bombarded by
restricted phone
number go ahead no because then that
encourages them to keep doing it to
you C they're calling again oh I just
said pick it up to den yeah pick it up
put it on the I don't want to I don't
want to get on the list of people that
can fall for it you know what I don't
even I I have my phone on do not disturb
and Silent 100% of the time bro you
don't say no yeah really I don't deal I
don't want to deal with anything on that
phone but I check my phone a lot what
I'm I'm always talking to you guys when
do I ever keep you guys waiting only
when you're in the middle of doxing
someone trying to stop you with a
million messages and pings on WhatsApp
well I mean that's during the show I
have I that's when I should be muting it
yeah right all right let's talk about ab
and preach are our
omelette the OM and amlet of knowledge
in order to comprehend so we were uh we
were reviewing
preach's um Michael Jackson yeah uh
cover he performed live for Que
queans comprehen in order to comprehen
to eat the the omelet of knowledge
you're going to need to break this my
boy those
eggshells That's my boy so they reacted
to uh our thing and I I'd say you know
when we were talking about it I think we
were being
like I said he thought it I thought I
said preach did a great job I thought he
killed it we all did yeah because he did
yeah was we said all nice things and so
they saw that
and I don't know if this is a bridge
building moment because you don't know
can't tell I think it might
be I think it might be a bridge building
moment I think it might but I don't know
because I can't read their
minds but let's
watch and then we can decide if we want
to build the bridge okay or if we want
to tear it all
down this is London Bridge baby it's
falling down here is the omelet of
knowledge he's not really an enemy I'm
being I'm being dramatic with these guys
ab and preach
um apparently in Quebec he's like a
local
celebrity and he does standup comedy and
apparently people like come to his shows
and
stuff yeah yeah what does he talk about
the like break the eggs I guess being a
little silly where's the a bridge here
yeah for sure it's just being a little
silly not
hateful wow you a okay come on go
easy on him go easy on preach we kid him
we kid him cuz we love him he made a
comment about your
boobies they got a lot of something they
got a lot of s I'm not going li like
they pulling out course I didn't even
know you made they talking about you I
mean first they're giving it up to to
the soundboard I man it is impressive
which is good you know back there I love
that but even the the haters can't even
deny that what we do here is they can't
magic they can't stop us frankly hit him
with the the squeak and the
the singing and the omelet I mean you
listen to this and you tell me who else
in order to comprehend you're going
to comprehend in order to comprehend to
eat the the object of knowledge you're
going to need to break
nobody also when I was watching their
video back I was just I was just
giggling so much about how what petty
little we are that we isolated
his vocal that's so I'm sorry but that's
so funny to do for no
reason all right go on what is that know
we're not their enemy the enemies of
their podcast anymore cuz remember
before you used to get mad when he saw
our name I hate these gu but but
not mad enough to to to watch the whole
videos no first of all I don't even
understand that insult if why would me
being mad want me to watch your videos
more that's probably in reference to
some specific time that I know he's
talking about this talking about this
yeah they they haven't they don't bother
me enough yet but I'll tell you
this I'm insane they're pathetic
they're Liars they're dishonest and
they're phonies I guess they're better
than fresh and fit and stuff for sure
like
well and then they make a video saying
how like she's a liar and I
don't I didn't watch it to be I watch I
watched some of it but it was upsetting
so I didn't watch it he just mad enough
to make assumption about what we're
doing and make assump about what we
saying without watching vide I think all
right come on you guys I've seen enough
you know what I mean but he's talking
about uh well anyway that clip I I uh
conceded that it was pretty cringy of me
to do the whole I'm insane thing in that
moment
but although they're they're bickering
over the they made the video accusing
the girl who called in of doing like a
fake me too which
I think it's a conversation we could
have with them maybe
but certainly not seeing eye to eye on
that one
there uh
but on a bridge you can see further than
you can on the street if it's if it's
curved if it's a curved
bridge and there's if the canal no if a
canal is running below street level the
bridge might just be at street level no
not if it's curving up cuz is at the
Apex you'll be higher than yeah but not
inherently huh not inherently the our
the bridge I'm building
is it's lots of types of bridge we're
going to build a bridge meet in the
middle where we have a two feet higher
we can see a little bit
more happen was he found out the homie
that was gasing him Hanan is actually
like a giant piece of that was
sending people and his community after
his wife and him and then he said you
know what these guys were right
about cuz they they cut the podcast you
know they stop doing of course of course
because of the because because he's
Jewish right oh and his uhhuh that's
exactly right right it's because I'm
Jewish um well okay so first let me say
this Hassan didn't send his fans after
me I'll just speak on him a little bit
Yeah but also I'll say this I'm glad
they're making fun of him and not
me you're just glad somebody else has
taking the you're saying you know what I
mean okay that's a I mean that alone is
Vibe of course but we love Han son he is
he is
family um it was more so his community
that
uh I don't know if that's a that's a
that's a meaningful
difference right well I hope people
don't hold us to the standard of what
our community does
right what is our community
do I mean you say that but what what do
they
do we our community is fantastic it's
all love yeah no that's true our name
one thing they've never cause us any
trouble
by I don't even want to go there well
just tell me and I can button
it or right it to me I have grown up
with man exactly let's just move on
let's just move on we love our community
folks everybody every single member of
our
community yeah I mean listen we've never
done anything wrong but okay but
even if they did something silly because
I don't know what you're talking about
but I'm sure it was silly and
harmless definitely silly and harmless
that's what I'm but it's not sending
like hate and death wishes
to uh supposed
friends
anyway Dan sent me a summary here what
do we
say uh come on that's that's
nebulous that's not a specific
thing with man but they also send lots
of love our fans are lovers first and
foremost that's true overall that is
true
yeah really was like that mustache man
wasn't so bad it was Wilding on him his
wife they had cartoons of his wife just
mowing down Palestinians like they was
posting crazy Ethan was breaking
down crying and his s was just like I
don't give a and I'm sitting in the
back like you thought we was the piece
of a Michael Jackson happen either
what are we talking about that
definitely did not happen well he was he
definitely didn't say what did he accuse
I don't give a no he didn't say
that he did not say
that um okay whatever this is about yeah
uh whatever right right we love Hanan
yes we do we ride with him yes that
being
said it's just nice to be over here that
I understand you know hunting season
you're used to being Target number one
so absolutely it's nice
Yeah song and we we uh ran AI through it
so it's just his voice so we could play
it for you guys uh well so there wasn't
a claim on the original i' say we should
watch the original oh no claim yeah okay
fantastic if you want to play both we
should watch the original and then what
and then let's hear just his vocals we
should do his vocals and then just
squeak squeaky Florence in the backg
here if you need
something we're good sound
board yo that is so loud though that
that is they purposely add sound effects
on top of no that's real dnud you
guys that's how of control come on I
know you all trying to be authentic but
like we can you're successful let's you
could got that fixed most likely right
absolutely I don't know how I mean I
don't know how do you how do you fix a
squeaky FL they talked about why they
don't fix it in the video okay they talk
about you all right I'm just saying I'm
GNA be using this one from now on there
you go I did it for us we appreciate the
clean sound it sounds fake it's so
squeaky kind of yeah I would get that
like on a free audio website and be like
that doesn't sound real it's too
much I love that people always make fun
of this floorboard but oddly enough
YouTube is all about being authentic and
kind of simple in that way I agree but
like you can you don't need to squeaky
that's not the it's not that disruptive
to be fair it's not it's funny we're
nitpicking it's more funny we are
nitpicking but I'll say this you guys
can be authentic without the
squeaks you guys are authentic without
the squeaks you do not need the squeaks
for your audience to see you as
authentic
Legends right Nice Bridge Building there
very well done well played sir see
higher yep look how much further I can
see what's the what's the biggest
biggest bridge in
Montreal True meet you there in the
middle Montreal Harbor Bridge ain't
show me a photo compared to the
bridge we're building show me a photo
let me see you it's a nice Bridge it is
elevated good we want a strong do we
really want a strong
bridge look at that well you're saying
we want a weak Bridge with them well I I
was
saying that's look at the vantage point
it it could be a bridge like the bridges
in uh Switzerland that are all rigged to
blow with dynamite in case of an
invasion so it's like you build the
bridge but you have a like a a fallback
plan it could be the Ambassador Bridge
which is the bridge between M uh the US
and Canada does have a draw bridge I
want a strong Bridge that's a strong I
want I want a bridge that will stand the
test of time that's what's the oldest
bridge in the world the we want a bridge
look it up yeah oldest bridge bridge
world
here's our Bridge man Ambassador Bridge
go that's where we come together and at
like ambassadors do make peace in the
Middle East they've never done that
actually they've never done that but
like ambassadors we will make peace I
peed in the backseat of a Camaro on this
bridge good memories peed in you peed in
a bottle I did yeah I peed in a Camaro
was there someone next to you anyone
next to you uh Lena was driving it was
my sister's car was there anyone next to
you no no no it was just the two of you
and you climbed in back to do it m
interesting yeah did you fill it up all
the way I did was it like a 12 O Coke
bottle or something uh I think it was
just a water bottle was all we had yeah
wasn't that big that's my fear of if I'm
like thinking about peeing in a bottle
while I'm driving which I don't do it
because I'm scared that I'm going to
overflow it and then Panic no it could
be disastrous I don't mean to uh break
up the Bridge Building here but they did
go after Olivia I was think happed
thinking about that okay you don't know
who Olivia she's the loser feminist
researcher right
and we got you're right we'll bring the
TNT out I also had to cut like a million
videos of them being anti-trans too so
right God you guys why do
you trans trans transgender trans trans
trans trans I just don't like the
Narrative of trying to like pile on like
there's a beef between you and Hassan
therefore I'm out yeah oh no you guys I
how can I build a bridge by myself brid
the bridge is made of paper mâché they
could they could maybe make a peace
offering to you
Olivia no not happening is the Damage
Done I brid I don't
really what I can move forward in my
life with things but I don't really
forgive if they said you know what sorry
we said that we didn't know anything
about you we were wrong o really I feel
like Olivia is usually so quick to
forgive too it really depends depend
maybe they come across the sincere and
they'll melt your heart maybe maybe play
the Olivia soundbite again so I can
remember exactly what they said okay if
you don't know who Olivia is she's the
loser feminist researcher who spends all
her Day on Reddit boards and thinks
that's research okay that's just
me that was so unnecessary
also Olivia does not really know how to
use Reddit thank you she is way too cool
to be on Reddit when I first got this
job I had no idea that different reddits
were like good and negative I just
thought that's where news was happening
mhm
mhm um what you said it wasn't this what
was it no it was when I was talking
about my experience I think they like
zoomed in on me my face being really
upset and they flashed to Amber herd
they did that they played like sad music
over her they did that they
did O that's
up I thought this was going to be a
peaceful video but now it's just all the
pain is I'm just digging the pain back
up back up can you pull that do you mind
if I watch that to J my
memory why would they do that because
they
suck that's super mean whenever we talk
about burning the witch
so this is the oldest bridge need this
oldest bridge in the world I don't want
to meet on that bridge anyway AR Bridge
bring it down but I mean it's it's
nearly 4,000 years old that's just that
bridge sucks it it lasted four Millennia
how it looks like thrown together look
at it how well made that is that
looks thrown
together I could build a bridge better
there's been no windy days y'all are
just you're doing anti- Greek
discrimination right now both of you
yeah I hate G the ancient Greek bunch of
[Music]
pedophiles where's that bridge go to
his
kid mhm oh not his kid but a kid
probably you know that's what they did
back then they did that look what it's
connecting and this is the apartment we
started filming in this is where we
pretty much started everything but a lot
of people try to use it against what's
this why is that guy doing a h Hitler
uh wait a minute why is he doing that oh
my God damn what did you
quickly
Hey listen with all the anti-Semitism in
the world today is this really the time
pulling this IM on a bridge is this the
oh that's the bridge yeah this and it
kind of leads to nowhere so it looks
nicer from the top I'll say
that also it's like not that big of a
ravine like you could walk through that
well it doesn't really do anything just
leads nowhere dumbass Bridge well I
think when they build
ITA P bridge bridge building idiots
dumbass P Bridge yeah dumb P Bridge
ped
bridge I I don't mind like to me I'm
like proud of the roots in a weird way
crazy than Flor complimented me you
wouldn't understand yeah did you you
really I really see it when they try to
use it hey with your cook okay then they
he goes on like a whole T we did not I
didn't
make wait hold on let me go back what
thanks floor complimented me you
wouldn't understand yeah did you you
really I really see it when they try to
use it hey with your cookie ass floor we
change your floor hey you broke
the reason why we even I
mean I didn't think you're broke but it
is funny you got to give it up you got
squeaky ass floor hey what your saky ass
floor
oh I'm trying to be nice I'm not
saying anything mean I could have but
I'm
not we change your FL well now now this
whole thing is is gone cucko because of
the it's gone a little cucko this isn't
what I hoped it would become yeah yeah
let me see what they did you you you
know someone who's always looking to
forgive people you're a redeemer Ethan I
I think that about myself it's 20 are oh
thank you not even being sarcastic here
I find that I'm very very as much
as I talk I find that I'm very happy or
very quick to forgive that being said
they wronged Olivia and that's not
something I can forgive right thank you
I absolutely give you guys 100% all of
the power to forgive on your own I
personally am just like not going to
entertain okay them that much that's
fair we trying to find that that time
stamp of what they said about
Olia or did they erase it was that the
one they erased you know got be I don't
know about that look like AB maybe found
it H3 how is H3 not Perma banned for
this she's the loser feminist researcher
who spends all her Day on Reddit boards
and thinks that's research okay so the
way she found this dude's name who they
incorrect by the way Reddit boards have
good ass research on it I don't know
what reddit's you're in but there's good
on Reddit I mean sometimes yeah
exactly sometimes but it's moot anyways
cuz Olivia is not a redditor that's
that's all the clip though I don't think
we need to watch
anymore this is all the clip you're just
trying to where they originally said it
right yeah I want to know I mean the
people it's I think it's important to
yeah that that was it I know Olivia
doesn't like to watch anymore of this
that's why heit what on Reddit boards
and thinks that's research okay so the
way she found this dude's name who they
correctly doxed if she went on her oh
the doxing thing that was such a silly
thing they blew out of
proportion um that was the worst day
ever I that's the biggest mistake I've
ever made and I will literally always
repent for
it um what happened I closed it this is
not going how I imagined it would
go good timing Zach
this is not the happy ending I was
looking for well maybe um you know uh
reacting to this video in detail was a
mistake Ethan it seems to have maybe
close close the video and just be like
you know what let bygones be bygones
what is a
bygone uh a bygone is something that has
gone by has is in the past so let them
let the past be the past
that a by what is a is hold on byon is
it like a
noun I've got a
bygone past outmoded oh I like outmoded
gone by or pass yeah the bygone days
it's gone by The Stonewall is from a
bygone age we just looked at a Stonewall
from a bygone
age oh
man um well here's a here's a positive
note they complimented Love's
pronunciation or the e z that was pretty
good accent that was a they like that is
it is itly yeah boy it is hey you can
clip that put it in your soundboard we
should that was really good you have it
Zach that
was yeah boy yeah a good yeah boy that's
awesome
[Music]
yeah my flavor this is there's no he's
not a fantastic his fit is anyway I this
is this has gone all
wrong
boy they left a comment calling me a
skinny
Legend they said well that's the real
that's that's the real that's all I saw
yeah everything else was blurry but I
get that they p
this comment shout out to Ethan though
man's lost a lot of weight and seems
happier and healthier since he quit the
podcast with his wife Hassan they
really hate us they are really which if
memory serves me right in that clip of
um that they cited ham was being he he
was being way more reconciliatory than
me yeah which yeah generally that is the
you're you're the you're the petty
so and and I and I say that openly right
yeah
also he he gives us details about the TV
show also the TV show wasn't a talent
contest the show is to pay tribute to
celebrities and one of the ways they do
it is to have people that celebrity
admires come and perform their favorite
scene songs a celebrity in question
requested preach to perform since he
admires
preach I think we actually did get to
that conclusion cuz yeah we we going
into that we were even saying like we
having a hard time getting Intel about
it but um I think a Canadian fan of Bars
by the end of that segment had sent an
explanation there it is did they not
finish the segment did they not finish
the video there is one see that's a good
call out because I feel they they
disappointed me here in one one part for
exclusive cont it's not going to be
there check out the pat oh here they're
talking about I watch but when they talk
about us making fun of the thing yeah
but don't make me stare make sure you
did it properly n no that's
weird listen I know you didn't do it cuz
I watched but I'm angry that he made me
watch I didn't make you to our patreon
listen to the one without backing
because of the audio Yeah okay it's it's
decent though you'll see but I'll say
this uh as a as a body of of people we
sending peace and love to Omelette what
they're sending peace and love to to
Palestine
cool go straight wait what is that a
Hassan joke or are they saying I don't
know if that's like a Jew joke an
Israeli joke or a Hanan joke or if I I
think that's just a that's a preach ISM
we need to start learning it's a CRA he
cracked The
Omelette boy but yeah free
Palestine but yeah I really don't know
what he was shooting for with that one
I'll say this because that's what my
falling out with well falling out I
don't mean that but like the I mean yeah
the show falling apart yeah over over
you know stuff but still like in that
well let's analyze I mean he's a
professional comedian so right it might
be body of of people we sending peace
and love to Omelette what sending peace
and love to to Palestine cool I just I
just don't see
what what's the joke
dude I'm not no I'm kidding I forgive
you already
man forgive you already that bridge I'll
tell you what when I saw those kicks and
those Twirls you did on stage oh no not
the Ambassador Bridge
no man that's the and that's the Apex
that's where we were supposed to stand
this is and this is the bridge you said
connects United States to
Canada oh yep mhm that's a bummer
oh
no we can rebuild it we can fix it we're
going to build back better mhm like Joe
Biden always they go straight
to what the
[Applause]
come on let the people AI is crap you
want to just give them a rendition no
come on let the people you know when I
said dark child that when you know a
song is going be fine when it starts you
did them
notes they're doing they're they're
riffing which is good and fine I'm just
trying to find this one uh part may you
can help me where they're talking about
the omet remember the black or white
about the omelette about how we make
reach for the omelet
stuff and then they have was he upset
that we were being culturally
insensitive to the French no he's been
cool he's not even French though he's
Canadian they inch
can with their Aran canadi anyone who
knows we we've been dancing singing from
the start no that's what happens when
you react to stuff that you didn't even
watch yes that's what happens Karma you
know what I mean but
karma so I respect that about him
generally you do react to things that
you haven't watched
before by the way but which is when you
react to something usually you haven't
watched it
before yeah I watched it this time is
that okay no I'm just saying CU he said
that's what happens when you react to
things you haven't watched
before
mhm this is not you haven't watched this
is not going well
yeah it is what it is they get upset cuz
they're insulting preach no it's fine
it's it's
fine now if it was me we got a
problem you can't be talking about me
noet bro H you call me no omet bro would
you have done nothing yeah of course
nothing huh what you want but I would
have been upset cuz I'm sensitive you're
not sensitive but we're not going to go
over that anything else you want to
say omelette no call me omelette again
they never explain why we call him
omelette cuz I I think it's great I
think it's fun
I got to explain that show them the
joke you know let's you know let's put
the mortar down and the bricks on
top you know one brick at a
time what are you going to do what are
you going to do what are you going to do
shut that camera off yeah what are you
going to do what are you going to do
yeah all right
um all right AB been preach everybody
yep new besti
alert I've been walking around my house
[Applause]
going
night there was another part I wanted to
see I forget God damn
it all
right what time is it 4:15 we got
anything
else um you know I have something I
really want you to watch great it's an
old oh at the top it's right here I
just highlighted it I'm making it real
big I got it the will am thing right
hell yeah so wait is this new or oh yeah
oh it's new so I don't know longtime
fans know that um I love will I am I
made several videos about him in my
early you know YouTube career M he's
just such a strange dude um and
he takes himself so seriously as like
this great uh inventor and Tech genius
it's it's really something but he's back
um and I can't wait to hear his ideas
they're always good Coca-Cola I had like
a perfect sentence like yo what's my
elevator pitch I'm like yo companies the
size of coke need to be verbs in society
if you don't believe me Google it she's
like wow Google is a verb I'm like right
Coke should be a verb too well what do
you think this conversation never
happened I don't know everybody he goes
into a lot of detail an he was saying
you'll see he said he was having these
conversations around like 2007 or8
that's when black IPS were top of the
world so maybe he's the one that made
the world realized that goo he turned
he's the one that turned Google into a
verb well no he's saying he identified
that Google is a verb and that's good
for Google so we need to turn Coke into
a verb Coke it yeah but you need coke it
really off the rails right after this so
Coke's verb should be Coke in Reverse e
KOC for ecosy E Community Eco concept
Eco creativity Eco collaboration we're
going to take your waist which is ptic
and aluminum you're going to create a
new base cloth and we're going to
license that base cloth to other
companies to execute their
sustainability effort
Levi je that's super the process of
transformation and making it reusable
and sustainable because waste is only
waste when you waste it so I have my
whole like concept down like yo check
that out right Eco cycle which is Coke
backwards can you repeat back what the
concept is yeah so um Coke backwards
right which is e c o or e
k yeah e e but he he removed the
so it says Eco so it just Eco but that's
e we're just a totally different word at
this point Co so he thinks people are
going to say yo let me eco that eock
that and how does that help Coke exactly
their name is not Eco by the way coke
doesn't need more brand recognition I
don't know I don't know well I am
they're pretty the most exposed brand in
the world maybe yeah they might be
actually yeah the yep
so and waste is only waste when when you
waste it so let's not waste it let's
renew it reuse it I pitch this to them
in
2008 and uh we have I haven heard how
did it go now that was the clip that got
posted on a sub it was very funny but
whenever I see Clips like this I'm
always like what is this podcast where
did this come from and I managed to find
it maybe some people in our audience
were already familiar with it's the next
Link in the doc if you want to pop that
open it's the concept of cocaa I heard
this one won a
uh waves word whatever it's
called Let Me Close all this so
yeah this is from uh the grace Beverly
podcast um yo Grace Beverly got will I
am why is he wearing the same thing oh
that was excerpt from this it's an
excerpt from this and I want you to
because when that clip ended I was like
I need more I need like I need to hear
more of his pictures and so this should
be timestamped to just as the the end of
the Coke story and you're going to be
surprised where this goes next 9,000
views by the way after 6,000 Subs 9,000
views what's going on there there's so
many of and there's such good ideas in
here so we so we ended up where no one
can own it if we're not
partnered they can't do anything with it
if we're not doing something around
sustainability that's why I love pitch
decks I pitch the concept to uh a
football player friend of mine I love
that he loves pitch decks like I don't
like executing I don't like making
because that always back I like pitch
this whole segment is about how much he
loves pitching people on ideas you got
to hear this idea back it up a little
bit you you got to hear this IDE he's
definitely an ideas man y you know took
us a year and a half or two years to get
the deal on who owns Coke in
Reverse I was like but I came up with
the concept I come I can't F fought
fought so we so we ended up up where no
one can own it if we're not
partnered they can't do anything with it
if we're not K is dying to do the eock
campaign oh man will sitting on gold
right there yeah not doing something
around
sustainability that's why I love pitch
decks I pitch the concept to uh a
football player friend of mine his name
is Jamal Anderson he played for the
Atlanta Falcons American football
by the way he I don't want to make any
accusations but his mouth is very dry
and his jaw is very active and so was
his tongue and I noticed this even back
when I made my videos about him
so he does seem very energetic as
well also his lips look kind of
white like powdery
white one day I'm like
yo I want to do a soundtrack to your
feet
he's like what okay cut
that what I'm like yeah think about it
bro everybody does soundtracks to
movies what about soundtracks to your
feet bro he's like well what are you
freaking going on about that would make
me really
uncomfortable I love how in his
retelling of his own story the other guy
in the conversation is like what the
creeped out what the are you
talking about bro have you been looking
at my feet the wrong with you yo
I want to do a soundtrack to your feet
what does that even mean like what does
that mean yo well he's going to explain
okay good yeah yeah he's going to
explain I was like hear me out how many
weeks is your training to go and play
pro he was like it's 12 weeks 12 weeks
right so for each week I'm going to make
a song going through her head right
now she's just like
what oh man she's gonna end this whole
long anecdote be like yeah that's crazy
so anyway she kind of has fous energy in
this clip yeah oh for real that's good
each mode of training that say or do
anything just nodding while he rants
those are the best
podcast really good you do because your
feet you need your feet to play your
sport no it's called football bro yo so
I'm going to make a soundtrack to your
feet you're probably going to get a shoe
deal right so instead of the song 12
Songs which is an album being sold at um
uh Tower Records or virgin mega store
we're going to sell them at Foot Locker
selling music at a shoe store because
you're going to selling his foot
soundrack soundtrack Ethan try and keep
up so he's making an album he making an
album sell at Foot Locker it's a concept
record that will be the Foot Locker
about this random NFL players feet so
what is it
like like like are we doing like is that
foot music to you but I don't know what
foot music is I don't know my brain is
not expanded enough yo yo I have a shoe
and it's soundtrack to your feet which
really the freaking theme songs and
commercials to your shoe that's going to
be so bro brilliant so he was like yo
all right let's do it I'm like wait wait
really that Ian so I was we I was signed
up to do it he gets hurt so I'm like
dang it my whole concept is
gone and so then I went to my friend I'm
like yo let's do a soundtrack to a beer
and so we went to we flew to Colorado
there's a beer called Kors there's a
be this
200r not heard of flew to Colorado had a
whole pitch I to made a pitch
deck I want to make a soundtrack to
your and so they're like we're not in
the music business I'm like yes you are
I don't know one bar that doesn't play
music where people aren't drinking this
is there was like tons of cuts there and
this is the original podcast so so that
was a bit nasty I
apologize what I didn't see the cuts oh
I zoomed in on her face you could see
here so he was like yo all right let's
do it I'm like wait wait really so I was
we I was signed up to do it he gets hurt
so I'm like dang it my whole concept is
gone and so then I went to my friend I'm
like yo let's do a soundtrack to a beer
and so we went to we flew to Colorado a
soundtrack to a beer I mean okay that's
commercial that's just a commercial
jingle we've done that we've done that
Kors has done that they probably even do
have a
soundtrack you know it's a jingle the
Kors family he invented doing a
jingle this is
2003 there's a cut flew to Colorado had
a whole crazy yeah I think they like an
AI I'm like yo I want to make a soundra
to your beer they cut out the and so
they're like like they probably just ran
it through an AI cut out the like Parts
yeah what we're not in the music
business I'm like yes you are I don't
know one bar that doesn't play music
where people aren't drinking your
product and listening to music for free
who's going to go to a bar that doesn't
play music and what do they who does he
talk to all day like there's somebody in
his life that listens to this all day
and I have to wonder who is it
assistant someone's being paid a lot of
money just to listen to this all
day what the bars for to buy
music or buy your
product so M you are in the music
business you just don't know
it because without without music your
product doesn't get sold at certain
locations so they they love my concept
they gave me the gig and if you go on it
I'm captivated by this I I'm really
curious where this is going the mouth
sounds are crazy yeah yeah I heard that
last real loud it seems like he has a
really dry mouth really sad right now
there's an album up there called must be
21 because in America that's the age for
drinking
there's a song in there called um let's
do it it was originally supposed to be
called let's get
started oh but they wanted me to change
the title to yeah you can't name it the
same title as your H song well this is
the prequel I don't think so no because
the the one we all know is get
restarted let's get restarted yeah but
he's dropping some knowledge about this
prequel that evidently existed okay hold
on let get started
um let's do it it was originally
supposed to be called let's get started
let's get started but they wanted me to
change the title to let's do it but that
song's not called let's do it he's made
a song afterwards and he wanted to give
it the same name as his hit song he I
think he said this was in 2003 I think
this is a prequel my friend but he but
he never okay but that song's not called
let's do it no I know I think we're
talking about two different songs here
entirely
um and then we eventually release a
different version of let's get
started there's an artist on that
compation talking where are we
in where did we start we were talking
about Pitch decks this dude is like I
mean he's he's shirt leet of the
entertainment world you think we can get
will I IM to come on and talk to us
about this guy I'll go get McDonald's
and let him keep telling us about tech
let's go will in here I don't know I
feel like I'd be me it wouldn't be good
cuz I just mean I would be mean even
unintentionally because it's like I'm
not I can't sit there as he goes on and
on about this you know Coke
backwards you think she forgot what what
they're talking yeah she's totally lost
she's like hoping that she can just
pretend like jump in with a new question
at some point yeah that's all she's
thinking about is her next question yeah
right when there's a pause Stevens he's
the type of dude though it doesn't
matter what you ask him he's going he's
gonna talk about what he's gonna talk
about legal name is John Stevens his
arest name that he became after that
project it's called John
Legend there's a person by the name of
Stacy that's on that project that then
became
Fergie so this must be 21 record was a
soundtrack to a beer but because the
beer company funded it they're not in
the music business so I ended up owning
the Masters
to something they paid for crazy
so y I always had this like good for you
you know looking at what what's
happening from an elevated view to then
make sense of it and be creative and
curious I'm trying to take an elevated
view on this monologue and I can't tell
what I'm looking
at pitch and uh
Fearless what's the worst going to
happen pitch something and somebody's
like nah so the whole premise of it is
to come up with the perfect pitch and
when did you start realizing that
actually kind of Entrepreneurship was
very much part of your job as a musician
all right he just answered that were you
not listening you're not listening
Lady Grace damn there's only 25
comments lovely have you gave him space
and time to feel comfortable enough to
express himself true okay so then they
like that she's not talking yeah fair
enough to live a creative life we must
lose our fear of being wrong okay that's
a quote by motivation mhm he's so neurod
Divergent and it's
magic maybe a little bit oh my God what
the
I mean okay
magic and then right he is nuro spicy
spicy nuro spicy
spicy what are the OB this is an odd
comment this is the strangest this oh
yeah it is I thank you this is such an
odd
comment yo yo yo why don't we make a
soundtrack about your
feet I still I still don't know what
that means man all right that was um
will I am everybody still got it he
still got
it I want to do a soundtrack to your
feet oh actually there's one more thing
I want wanted to watch short oh
something new wait I think you're going
to want this is should be the
punctuation mark on the episode cuz this
is was right big news oh boy this is
massive guys all right big
news so it's a
slide
mhm it shows 46,000 people watching nice
nice nice nice now next okay I can't
sleep hold the phone wait hold the phone
but that's so
dumb hold on hold on hold on does he
does yeah yeah wait oh yeah that's the
same wall is this
a is this the first time someone's
pointed this out is this a
relevation perhaps Revelations
Perhaps Perhaps do you what is it
possible that this is all in his camper
yeah right ni try yeah I know maybe does
he have a wall like like this in his
camper yeah he could maybe he rebuilt it
cuz he to be an exact replica of his old
yeah that's possible this is very daming
it is cuz he has no shirt on I mean no
he's in her bed yeah
he's so so hold on fake divorce or post
breakup sex Li about us could be yeah
that frankly okay I know couples they
they hook up uh from time to time uh
during when they're going through a
breakup divorce whatever it's
complicated he posted this in the middle
of the night I can't sleep with the
lights fully on it's probably not in the
middle of the night he probably is like
chilling with the kids the family is
like oh let's I got to post a little
thing where I look lonely let me just go
and take a little photo well what
about because she Pro she lets him in
the house he goes there and spends times
with the kid maybe she's out on a date
and he got in her
bedp so he could smell it and stuff this
isn't enough evidence I don't know what
to tell you
brother certainly evidence that CLE in
the it's absolutely her bed 100% that's
true but absolutely what you take away
from that I think it's silly to take
away anything else than that it's hard
to take anything else away it's hard
unless see maybe he's just really even
more pathetic than we thought he's in
there smelling her
pillow and she's out on a date that must
be it he's babysitting the kids he ain't
smelling her pillow bro you don't think
so
smelling something else he ain't
smelling the pillow what's he smelling
or panties is that what you're getting
at I think he's a sick
wow I mean yeah maybe oh my God all
right thank you Zach we love that about
you you're probably right it's possible
I mean if he's in there sniffing her
pill he's in there sniffing her panties
sure I mean why make two
trips you know he's got a drawer in his
camper full of he's got a drawer in his
camper full of her stolen panties yeah
two birds wait this is
nuts yeah what is happening why are you
guys doing
this this is this is
like 90% something there's some fishy
business here yeah one other
alternative old
photo no what' you say old photo but
this is their new house isn't it not
like brand new they Liv there together
old photo H why would he post an old
photo of himself he take that phot I saw
him wear that
bracelet um don't another picture I'm
just throwing out some other options
here I appreciate it I appreciate
it well we're going to have to they need
to answer to
[Music]
this they will they will in like a week
or two they'll post a YouTube video
we're back we didn't get we're our our
weddding
marri the top comment is yeah it's
pretty obviously is all fake Ethan is so
gullible come on chill dude just because
I want to believe given some pretty good
rationale to be you guys might still be
wrong I don't know if they're getting
back together it could have been a a
Pity sex it could have been no that's
what I'm saying absolutely could have no
100% post post break up hookup he's
there he's there all time he's outside
yeah could not be more
convenient nope it's about
sex um but it's not looking good didn't
someone say that they were trying to buy
an RV to travel the world I can see them
using the rumors to jump start the
purchase of the RV yep how do you hold
on you're not going to you know you're
not going to take a RV around the world
yeah that would be
tough will if you can't afford your
house maybe they're going to f it to
well not actually travel the world but I
mean maybe they can't afford their house
and they're going to they're going to
get away together they leave together in
their house leave the kids no seems
whole family and I mean let me just say
too if this does end up being fake and a
scam or whatever what I mean obviously
on it face that's a psychotic thing to
do to like try and trick your audience
or whatever but also with like the kids
involved it's like it's really having
them participate in this ruse that you
their parents are getting a divorce
they've that is beyond psycho which
like they are and maybe that is what's
going on but I think it's reasonable
to not fully commit to the to the fake
theory if they're faking it that doesn't
necessarily mean that they're going to
even
reconcile they might never say it's fake
mhm well we'll see we will see my theory
is two weeks Boom YouTube video week I
feel like this is so up it this
of all I mean they've done a lot to
tarnish the reputations but this this is
crazy cuz I I'm think I don't think
they're that poor cuz he can still land
box he can still land some boxing deals
and we know how much money they it's
really hard to tell how much money they
have I I I don't know I think because
they they've got 20 million subscribers
or something like that right it's
they've been making a lot of
money for a long time and now these
Snapchat deals boxing I'm sure he can
still get they lost so much money on
that house and he got sued and she's
being sued I feel like they were living
Way Beyond their means like yeah they
were big YouTub but I don't know they
were they were living it up but if they
are getting like two or three roll of R
it was like ridiculous if they're
getting sued don't you think that would
take longer CU they got sued maybe two
or three years ago they could stall that
forever right not forever have lost
the money they could okay you can't sell
forever no not forever but couple years
yeah more more than this I feel like
they wouldn't have had to pay out the
money they're going to spend all the
money well they can take their assets
too and they'll repossess their RV and
yeah cuz they I feel like they have a
lot of personal cash but then just the
company gets sued and they are not
liable personally man this is not
looking good for
them this is not looking
good we got to watch closely everybody I
hope you're all watching I Don't Want to
Miss a
detail to miss
the
um all
right
that's about it that's it 3 hours and 31
minutes on the do ab been preach I'm
here to build a bridge I'm a I'm a BGE
build I'm a carpenter like Jesus
Christ he was a carpenter and I love
wood I'm a Woodman do you but here's
what I you respect wood I respect wood I
would never put a cold drink on wood
without a without a a coaster a doily
final season baby coming this
Sunday oh really yeah that's huge man
it's the end of era members go up thank
you so
much1 wow thank you send Cody to driveby
to check on them oh God I wouldn't even
do that to them yeah I know members go
up S oh twice did you donate twice or
just the same no I just we both sent the
message thank you members go up we' love
you you are the man or one man or or or
you know in between is in between
okay sure members go up as it's a
spectrum oh he's a guy yeah okay
good but I'll say this ab and preach
maybe what you said to Livia was kind of
up you know maybe some
reconciliation an apology I don't think
at least apologize for calling her a
redditor that's the really up
thing yep for putting her
face oh yeah yeah that's messed up you
got to you got if you guys can just I
just you know apologize to Olivia for
that that edit you did then I think we
can we
can we can build Bridges all the way to
heaven um also was there something else
that was uh unforgivable the trans stuff
did they they've been making less trans
videos we might have got through to them
to that actually I don't know if that's
true I should check no idea if that's
true let me see
Abba and preach let's just wrap it up
let me just take a quick browse okay
let's see if there's any trans uh videos
in the
recent uh tabs here here's
me
transgender this looks kind
of okay well the title is ambiguous so
I'll count that um I don't see anything
yet
I don't see anything
right Saturday night well they post a
lot I'm at four weeks but I don't see
anything about trans or gay
people
right that's a leaf we love that leaf
being
turned we love that leaf
folks there it
is
so let's build a
bridge um that's
it what do you yeah I don't see
anything okay
[Music]
whatever
it then I did I I'm pretty sure I said
that on the air before and you probably
shouldn't have that time
too why well he I don't know about him
yeah everybody thanks for
watching nothing like ending the show on
a button people say no Bridge yeah yeah
I think everybody's pretty out got to be
honest with
you I mean why do you care like they
they're not that cool or entertaining
because I just it's 2024 that's
why New Beginnings Building Bridges you
know it's I like to have less enemies
more yeah you can have more less enemies
but that doesn't mean you have
toces the thing is like yeah I mean you
look at people uh like Jeff for example
he's outlier but an example of
blossoming beautiful friendships that
Rose From the Ashes of a of a burned
Bridge you
know and we did like a Harry Potter
magic
wand Mary Poppins that
should we do a
poll
Ethan let's wrap it up no Bridge man
yeah I'm sorry Olivia no Bridge
that's I didn't bear that in
mind I'm going to throw him over a
bridge how about that maybe none of that
okay fine she loves it so it's fine I
couldn't throw you guys you guys are pro
you guys are probably way bigger than me
I couldn't throw y'all and I wouldn't
either I wouldn't do that no you would
never throw I would try to kill I don't
want to kill you guys definitely like
can we at least agree on that 100% like
can we meet on that bridge yeah I'll
meet you on that bridge nice see I
that's progress yeah yeah it's
good all right well so much for that uh
thanks everyone for watching we had a
lot of fun here
today and um today's Monday so we'll be
back on Wednesday mhm not tomorrow huh
not tomorrow and again reminder for
members tomorrow's episode will be on
Thursday which is the new day for see
you next
Thursday Tuesdays for the uh for the
memes
um anyway thank you everybody have a
great evening see you next
[Music]
time